hey everyone I'm Cody Seibert and
welcome to a full-stack tutorial where
I'm going to show you how to build a
front-end single page application using
view Jas and also using view X as our
state store and then that's going to
connect to a back-end written in Adonis
Jas basically to create our REST API and
then I'm going to deploy this on
digitalocean after we finish and so let
me just show you really quick what I'm
going to be building basically it's a
very simple to-do list application
whoo-hoo in the left we have projects so
we can click different projects here to
change we can create projects edit them
and delete them
and then for each project we can create
different tasks and that also marked
them as completed go ahead and delete
some edits um or of course you can log
out and then you can log back in
so a very very simple application
hopefully this is a good start just kind
of explain the concepts of view in Adana
so let's just go ahead and get started
building out this application alright so
now that we know what we're trying to
build let's go ahead and create a new
repository so on my github account and
click new this is her people who don't
know how to create a repo so I'm gonna
name the repo view adonis to do go ahead
make that MIT and I'll create that repo
once my repo was created and I was gonna
go ahead and click this clone or
download and then copy this to my
clipboard then in my terminal of es code
I'm going to go into my workspace I'm
gonna do git clone and type in that repo
URL
and go ahead and just CD into that
folder in fact I should probably open
the folder here in my workspace so for
this tutorial I'm going to split it up
into two major sections the first
section I'm going to focus on building
out the rest api using Adonis J s and
then the second section I'm going to be
connecting to that rest api using view
J's for the front end so if you're not
really interested in learning how to use
a dentist to build a REST API feel free
to skip forward to the second section
and I'll put a timestamp in the
description below
so again we're using Adonis J s to build
out our REST API and basically that is a
label clone an MVC framework for
building up websites I'm not going to go
into too much detail on the docs or
explain all the different features and
functionality instead what I want to do
is just use it explain the things that
I'm doing as I'm doing them and then
leave it up to you to learn more about
the framework in the future so to start
using a donis let's go ahead and go to
their website and just look at the
installation section
basically to get started they say you
need to install a global adonis CLI tool
which i already have installed so i'm
not going to run this command and then
after you run the command you can do
Adonis help to get an information about
what you can run with the CLI let's go
ahead and do that so if I do with
Donna's - - help it's going to print out
all the different commands we can run an
Adonis now when you're starting off with
a new project the most important command
would be obviously is the new command
right so we're gonna do ad honest new -
- help to get more information on that
command if you see here we can pass
something called API only and that's
kind of what we're gonna be using for
this because we don't care about
rendering views and stuff on the backend
and we're going to be using View j/s on
the front end with that being said let's
just do ad honest new type in the name
of our project and in this case I'm just
gonna do server I like to separate my
server code from my client code and then
I'm going to pass that API only flag and
as this is running it's going to create
a bunch of different files in our server
folder
and give us a very bare-bones Adonis
setup which we can start running and
developing or rest API so now that of
the Adonis CLI is done creating a new
project let's go ahead and look at a
important command that we can use for
starting or serving our server so again
if we do Adonis - - help it'll tell us
all the commands and then notice that
there is a serve man which starts our
HTTP server well do Adonis serve like a
knife and help and we have additional
options that we can use in the most
important one is - - dev to start a
local dev server so I'm going to Adonis
serve I can - dev and of course make
sure you're in the server folder got the
CD into that and I'll rerun that command
and after this runs it's going to host a
server on port 3 3 3 3 if I go to my
terminal or go to my chrome and go to
localhost 3 3 3 3 notice that we get a
JSON response back from our donna server
so we're good to go we have it done is
set up and we have it running another
cool thing I'll state about this donna
surf command is that as you edit your JS
files and save them it's going to
restart your server for you
automatically so it's kind of using like
no daman behind the scenes we're just
watches your files and restarts them so
before we get too much further into this
tutorial let's go ahead and commit what
we have I want to say initial Adonis
setup
so at this point let me just go ahead
and give a quick overview on some of the
files that are generated I'm not gonna
go over all these files I'm just going
to focus on the ones we need to
implement our functionality and then we
can kind of cover more as time
progresses so the first one we want to
cover is inside the Start folder there
is a file called a RAL CAS and basically
this file is for declaring your routes
so I mean it looks very similar to
Express or Cola or happy where you have
a router object you give it a command
such as git postally patch whatever you
pass it a URL and then you pass a
callback function though nothing too new
here second file or folder I want to
show is inside the app folder by default
we're giving a models folder which has a
user J's model
so if we look at this basically we're
declaring a lucid model which has a hook
attached to it so before we create a
user model we're going to hash the
password
and then at the end we just return that
model so nothing to do insane here and
then inside the hooks folder we have
that user J s file which declares that
hash password hook go in here basically
we say if the user instance has a
password attribute we're just gonna hash
it and then put it back into the past
before we save this model and so for
those of you who aren't really familiar
with the hell-like or ORM does work
typically there's a bunch of hooks that
exist around models like before you
update them before you create them
before you save them that you can kind
of attach callback functions to let
manipulate your data before it actually
hits your database mmm and this thing
with like getting data you could do a
hook before you fetch the data or app
you fetch the data to manipulate the
data inside your models so I'm not going
to dive too much into hooks or that type
of stuff feel free to look at the docs
if you want more information but the
main takeaway is we have by default a
user model
so you'll notice here there's no
attributes so associated with this user
model inside this file and that's
because if we go back and look at the
database folder there are a migrations
folder which has a user J's migration in
it so inside here this is where we
declare what properties should be
associated with the users table
so basically when we run our migration
scripts it's going to create a user's
table it's going to give it a user name
email and password
and then if we were to roll back our
migrations just gonna drop this table
alright so another quick quick recap we
have a routes file where you declare
your routes we have a models folder
where you declare your models and then
you declare your tables that will be
associated with that model in your
migration scripts alright so now that we
kind of glossed over some of the files
and folders that are included in the
adonis CLI new projects let's go ahead
and get started on trying to implement
some functionality so the first thing I
want to do with our to-do list tutorial
application is I want the ability for
users to register new users or new
accounts so how would we do this
obviously the first thing we want to do
is create a new endpoint or new route
where they can hit with a post request
to create a new account if I go to the
Start folder and go back to my routes
ijs file inside here we can simply do or
route dot post because we're doing a
post request and then we can do
something like off slash register and
some type of callback function and it's
I'm just going to return another hello
world message just to kind of
demonstrate what's going on so if I were
to save this file and then go to another
app that I have installed a running
called postman we can make example
requests to our API just to test it out
so remember our endpoint is off slash
register it needs a post request so if
we go to postman which is here this is
on the post main app it's really useful
for testing your REST API s we type in
the location of that URL auth slash
register and I tell it to do a post
request and I give it to a body in fact
I don't think I even need to give it a
body so I'll just go go ahead and click
send notice that it sends back our hello
world message so we created a register
endpoint that returns a message awesome
first steps are completed so for the
second step we instead want to put our
callback logic in a controller and not
have it all defined in one file of Rous
jeaious so if we were to go to our
second terminal and remember that we
have all these useful commands which we
can use to run and create our Adonis app
one of the commands is make controller
so if I do add honest make controller
help get more information on that
basically a week and run is honest make
controller ass at the name of our
controller which in this case I'm just
going to say a user and that will create
a controller file inside the again make
sure I'm in the server folder keep
reading to do that well first of all
that's going to ask if you want it to be
a WebSocket channel or an HTTP request
I'm gonna say HTTP request and notice
that it's going to create a app dot
controllers folder HTTP controllers file
here so let's go ahead and look at that
file and see what it created
is just a simple JavaScript class
nothing too special here but what we
want to do is we want to define methods
in this class so in this case we're
going to say register and let's return
that hello world message
you
and then to bind that to one of our out
so we simply go back to our routes file
and then instead of passing the callback
function here we can just say user
controller dot register
so again let me save that file and go
back to my first terminal just to make
sure that the server restarted and then
if I go back to post man and click send
we get that same response back main
difference is we're just binding to the
controller file and then more
specifically to the action or method
that's declared inside that controller
class so before we get too ahead of
ourselves let's go ahead and do a little
bit cleanup so first of all I'm gonna
remove this get request method because
we're not gonna be using that so another
cool thing adonus has is you have the
ability to group routes with a prefix so
let's say I wanted to append slash API
in front of all these different routes
that I had so if you imagine I had like
10 different routes and I want to app in
API to all of them you could do it this
way where you have a bunch of copy and
paste like URLs with the same prefix
or one way to do it is I just simply do
route group asset a callback function
put my route in
and then after the group you just say
prefix with API so now when I save that
I try to hit the route that we had
before it's going to return an error but
now I can actually hit it with the API
prefix
so that's pretty cool and then you know
sometimes you want to have different
versions so this might be version zero
and then down the road a year from now
let's say you need a version one that
get deployed you just saying change that
to be one and then you have all of your
different routes for the v1 here let's
go ahead and try to get back on track so
what were we originally doing we are
trying to create a new register in point
where we could pass in an email and a
password in the payload and then have
that created in our database so let me
just go ahead and remove b0 because I'm
not going to be using that in this
tutorial and then if I go to my user
controller what we want to do is we want
to be able to grab the request body that
was sent in so as an example if I were
to post some JSON to the endpoint so if
you see here we have an email and a
password sent we should be able to use
that in our controller so the do so
let's go ahead and first grab that
request object which is available using
object deconstruction here
and then inside this we can go ahead and
pull out the email in the password again
using object deconstruction from request
all so requests out all is going to grab
and merge our query string parameters
together with our post to payload body
and then we have the ability to grab the
properties like so and again we're just
going to print these out and just make
sure that everything is working as
expected so if I do that post request I
go back to my terminal I see that
testing and the password is printed out
to our terminal so we grabbed the
parameters or the payload body
successfully using something like this
the next step - how would we register a
user is we need to use the lucid model
to create and persist a new user to the
database so to get started on that let's
go ahead and include that user model and
then inside a dantas there's a keyword
called use so instead of user and
require they recommend you use the
keyboard to use and that's just because
this the inverse of controller method
that they're using allows you to easily
mock out and fake these during your
testing another cool thing is you can
just do the relative you don't have to
do like dot slashes your relative paths
to your file to get this to work instead
we can just do the absolute path so app
dot models dot user so that's going to
grab the app models dot user file here
which is a lucid model
and now that we have that model we could
simply just do user dot create asset the
email ask the password and then of
course we also declared something else
called a username which we're going to
be setting to the password in this case
and we need to just at the end return
the user so one thing I'll notice or
I'll point out is that these are
typically async methods so dot create or
save or whatnot so in order to
successfully use them you need to make
sure you put a weight in front and of
course in order to use a weight you need
to make sure you use the keyword is
async in front of your method so now if
I say this I should be able to create
that user when I do my post request I
got a little an error here and the error
is saying I don't have sequel 8-3
installed so let's go ahead and do that
if I go to my terminal and just install
that that will allow us to actually
connect to our sequel Lite server
because you need to make sure you
install the specific driver of the
database you're using so if we're using
my sequel or Postgres you need to make
sure you install it the correct driver
and in this case we're using sequel Lite
hmm so we should be able to just install
that we should be good to go let's try
it again and hopefully it works so if I
click send we are getting yet another
error so let me see what's going on here
and one thing I do to kind of debug is I
have jsbin loaded up I could have paste
the HTML fine here
this is saying that there's no such
table as users
and the reason that this is throwing an
error is because we forgot to run our
migration scripts so let's move on to
yet another topic which is migration so
if I open up a new terminal here and do
Adonis help you can see what command we
have related to migrations if you see
here there's five commands for
migrations the one we're kind of I'm
curious to use would be migrations colon
run and that's going to run through your
migration scripts and run anything that
it hasn't already ran yet so here I'm
just into Adonis migration run run that
that's going to create our user table in
our token table so finally if I were to
do a post request on that endpoint we
should be able to persist that user and
look it did we got our email back we got
a password which is hash back we got our
username created at updated at and we
got an ID so just to verify that this is
actually persisted to the database if we
try to do this again notice we get an
error back if we look at this error it's
going to say that a constraint failed
there's no unique user email so
basically this error is saying that
we've already used the email and we
can't use it again so we know that is
trying to create that same user and put
into the database it's throwing an
exception and it's sending a 500 status
code back with an error message
awesome so as a really really quick
recap we created a new route which
accepts a post request to off the slash
register we prefix it with API and we're
binding that to the user controller
register action or method and inside the
user controller we made an async
function which takes two requests it
takes two parameters or body from the
request we use object deconstruction to
grab the email and password we create a
user using that email and password in
setup a username important make sure you
use a weight here and make sure you have
a sink here we get the user that was
created and we return it back to the
user and then using postman we saw that
when we tried to create a user so if I
do testing 2 or 3 it should create a new
user with testing 3 and send it back to
us well so now that we know how to
create new routes and controllers and
stuff let's go ahead and try to create a
new one called login and what
is gonna do it's going to check the see
if the email password provide matches
what is actually in the database so to
do so again we just need to make a new
method here inside this controller
called async login and that's going to
take the request object for now
and again we need to grab the email and
password from that request I'll just do
that and then secondly there's something
cool that's already built in to Adonis
which is an auth property that's passed
in here and basically what auth does is
it has a couple of helper function
functions on it that allows you to try
to authenticate your user so if I were
to do kama auth we now have access to
that auth controller in the main reason
we have access to that is if we look at
our app dot J's file here inside the
Start folder there's a provider which
was declared called the auth provider
which gives us access to that off thing
our author object
this wasn't here we want to be able to
do that and then what type of
authentication are we actually using so
if we were to dive into the config
folder here and look at SAS notice that
there's a couple of different off types
that are kind of built in we have
session we have basic auth we have GWT
so by default this is using the JWT auth
and if we look down at the GWT
configuration notice that it's pointing
to our user model it's going to
automatically try to fetch based on
email and password so these are the two
columns that it's going to look at and
it's going to use the secret key here to
define a new JWT
token so if you don't really know that
much about JWT I suggest you go read up
on it I'm not gonna really give you that
much of a deep dive on it
but just know that this authentication
object that we're using it's just going
to look at our database and it's going
to create a key for us if the user is
successfully logged in so doing so let's
go back to our controller remember we
brought in this off object what we want
to do is we want to try to authenticate
the user so we're going to say cons
token is equal to a weight off dot
attempt and then we're going to pass it
our email and we're gonna pass it our
password and then we're gonna return
that token so if this is successful
we're gonna get a token send it back to
the user if this fails is probably gonna
throw an exception and send back an
error to the user if I save this file
this last part is we need to go to our
routes file and we need to declare a new
endpoint so that we can actually try to
register our login so I'm going to copy
and paste this line 19 and instead of
register I'm going to do login and then
login for action here save the file and
now at this point I should be able to
try to log in with that same username
and password that we just registered
with so you remember we registered with
testing at gmail.com and that's the
password oh if I just copy this payload
instead go to my off slash login
endpoint and click send
we get back a response that has a token
in it but for those who don't know what
a JWT token is basically it's just a way
to cryptographically sign adjacent
object if I were to take this token and
if I go to jadibooti dot IO I can paste
my token into their website and it's
going to decode it for me if you notice
here after I pasted it in this is the
data that's encoded inside of that
payload basically just has to use your
ID so if you notice here it's a 1 just
to kind of further demonstrate that
remember we made another account called
testing 3 I try to log in with that it's
going to give us a different token if I
want to
code that token inside this website
notice that the user ID here is a two so
behind-the-scenes adonis the auth module
is just going to fetch the user from the
database verify that the user name and
password match up correctly and then if
it does it's going to just encode a
token that has a user ID in it so the
cool thing about this is I can come into
this token and just make random changes
to it
but if I do
to fail the signature that only the
surfer knows about
so with that being said basically any
token that the server assigns and since
to the user we know a certainty that no
one else can modify that token and send
back to us and we can kind of cover an
example in a little bit because we're
not fully done implementing
authentication yet so I'll keep this
website up and let's go back to our code
and just kind of look at one more thing
that we can refactor so another thing I
wanted to do is when you register your
user you're probably going to need that
same token right so what I like to do is
instead of just returning the user we
created
I'm just going to return this dot login
and then past the arguments that were
passed into this request and in this
case we don't really need the user
anymore so now that when we register or
if we login we pretty much get this
payload back every time so if I go back
to register and I make a new account
testing 100 we get back our halo that
has a token in it awesome so we just
made a new login method we modified the
register method to call a login after we
register and then we created the route
to allow us to register and login we're
making some good progress now we just
need to UM move on to creating some new
database models before we move on to
that let's just go ahead and commit what
we have so I'm going to say registration
slash login and commit that and then we
can start fresh
back into this file 17 so since we are
planning to make a to-do list
application one thing I want to include
is a new project model so I plan to
separate my data into projects then
inside the projects we have tasks so
at the Adana CLI and see what commands
we can use to try to help us create a
new model so I do a Donna's help notice
here we have a make model Adonis make
model help and basically we just pass
the name of the model and then there's
also like a controller and migration if
you want to create a migration for the
model and in this case we do also want a
migration so be sure to include this -
in so again we wanted a project model so
if I say project and then pass - M
that's going to create us a project
model inside our models folder
ruch might be is code and then also we
get a migration script old projects so
first off let's go to our projects
migration and we need to make sure we
declare some attributes on our projects
before we run our migration scripts so
to do so I'm going to look at the users
and just kind of copy this one line here
and we want our projects folder to have
a title that's going to be a 255 max
length string and I'm just going to
remove the rest because I don't care if
it's unique and I don't care if it's
null or not second thing I want to do is
a project belongs to a user right
so inside our migration script if I look
at token they have an example of how to
do that
basically if I copy this line and go
back to my project schema
but that up here we want to us fill e8
the project to a user so we need to make
sure I'd use your ID column exists on
the project's able so we're saying yes
it's an integer of user ID it's unsigned
it references the ID in the users table
and then the last part is we need to go
into our projects bottle and we need to
make sure we declare an association so
if we look at the token J s file here
I'm sorry the user
is file
you
what we can do to declare associations
is simply just copy and paste this
project are this tokens method and
instead we're gonna name it projects and
this is gonna say this that has many app
that model that project and this just
tells lucid how to look up articular
associated records using the project's
method so literally inside of our
controller we can do user dot projects
and that's going to fetch us all the
projects associated with that user and
then the second thing we want to do is
we want to go back into a project model
and create a new method called user to
declare that Association in the other
way so I'm gonna say return this that
belongs to app models user and this is
just saying that a project that belongs
to a user and then a user has many
projects so that allows us again to
easily look up data both ways depending
on what type of lucid model we have
instantiated in our code and this will
make more sense when we actually start
using it so again we created a new model
called project which created us a
migrations file we declared a title
inside that migrations projects table
and we also declared a user ID which
references the users table and then we
declare some associations in our project
and a user model so what we want to do
is we need to run our migration again so
if I do a migration run that's going to
only run that project migration script
because we've already ran those past two
right so now in our database we should
have a table called projects and that
should be ready to go awesome so the
second thing is we need to create a new
controller and route so that we can
actually create new projects right
if I just closed all of these and then
we can start doing that remember an
Adonis we have a create or a make
controller method so here if I do make
controller so Adonis and make controller
help if they get more information I'm
going to pass it the project as a name
so that we have a new controller called
project and that's going to be an HTTP
type of controller an inside of a
project controller let's just go ahead
and do a index method
this method is supposed to do is
supposed to return all the projects that
are associated with the user and of
course we don't have a create method yet
so we'll have to make one in a second so
in order to do so we're gonna need that
off plug-in again
and it luckily off has a nice little
utility function called it user if I do
Const user equals a way to off that get
user that's going to fetch us to user
which was associated with the JWT token
that we passed in so again if I just
print out user here and then return
I'm random message for now we should be
able to create a route which is going to
point to that controller so here I can
say route to dot and get and that's
going to be on projects and that's going
to be on project roller dot index
the inertia
so go ahead and save my server and I
should be able to try to hit that
projects in point and in this case I'm
going to pretend like we didn't pass an
authentication token and this should
throw an error because we haven't
actually passed a JWT token like we said
we needed to WC here I expect the token
cost user a weight off the docket user
and we're actually getting this because
I probably forgot to add async so
remember make sure you always add async
if you're using a weight here
and I'll try to hit that endpoint again
see what the air is and we get an
invalid a JWT token right JWT must be
provided so at this point what we want
to do is when we declare the route we
also want to declare a meadow where
function so that we can parse a JWT
token from the request so inside of our
line 22 where we declare our index we
want to make sure that we add a middle
where all until it that it's going to be
an awful so basically we're going to
authenticate the user with that J DBT
token before we run our controller here
so again if I try to hit that endpoint
we're gonna get back an error again
Sanjay DBT must be provided so let's go
ahead and try to provide that J to be T
token so if I go back to login and I
just login with our testing at gmail.com
user and I grab this token typically the
way to pass a JWT token is inside the
header you have an authorization key and
then you pass it something called bearer
and then the token like so
and an inside postman what we have is we
have environments where we can just set
up kind of key value pairs so we can use
those in all of our requests so if I
look at the environment here I already
have one set up called authorization
which is set to a token so let's change
it to the token I just copied and put
bearer in front and this is just the
nama clay sure we use because it's a
barrier type token go ahead and update
that close out of that and then I'm
going to make my request and see what
happens
so this point we get a message back that
says hello world and then if we were to
leave off this authentication token
we're going to get back that same error
saying that GWT token was not provided
this is also going to check your token
to make sure it is valid so if I were to
go and try to create and spoof my own
token and send it to this endpoint it's
not going to work as expected
so going back to our code the main thing
that we wanted to kind of show is that
once we fetch off that get user it
prints out that user information here so
we have access to user ID inside of this
controller if we wanted to use it I'll
go ahead and just print that out at the
endpoint one more time
and notice here it's printing out one
because you remember in JWT i/o when I
decode this token it's printing out user
ID of one and what that does is going to
fetch the user from the database using
UID and then we have access to that user
model here okay so we're almost done
with this project index method the next
thing we need to do is using that user
we need to fetch and return all of the
projects that are associated with that
user so if I do return a weight user dot
projects dot fetch
that's going to use our associations to
fetch all the projects that are
associated with that user if I save this
go back in request that endpoint it
should return back in mtra because we
don't have any projects created yet
which leaves us to our next route let's
go ahead and create a create in point so
if I do a sync create I'm going to take
an auth in a request and let's kind of
step through what we might want to do
right so we're first need to verify that
the user as the token passed in so if I
go to routes I'm just going to create a
new post request to slash projects it's
going to call or create action and then
again make sure they're authenticated
and then we want to grab that user so
cost user is equal to a weight off bag
get user from the database so we have a
lucid model instance we can use we want
to grab the title that was passed in in
the payload
so for example if we were to go back and
post a project we're going to pass the
title Yolo here and we're going to fetch
it from the request here
now we want to create a new project but
we have an included project yet so first
we need to say bring in cost project
from app dot models that project and
then we need the creative project so
project is equal to new project this is
going to create us a new instance of our
lucid model for the project
we want to fill in or set values so one
thing I could do is I could do project
title is equal to title or something you
can also do is project that fill and
then pass it an object and that's going
to set anything that you pass in so if I
were to say name and name exactly and if
name actually existed on the database
it's going to put name on to that
project to but it doesn't so let's just
get rid of that and then finally we want
to create the project and associate it
with the user right so if we do a weight
user dot projects dot save and passes
the project and then finally we can
return that project
so recap we created a route for that
projects create method we make sure it's
authenticated you grab the user we fetch
the title from the request we create a
project and fill in that title
information we associate the project
with that user and then we return the
project back so let's go ahead and try
to hit this endpoint now though I'm
gonna click send it works successfully
and it returned us the project that it
created so it has an ID of one as a user
ID of one has the title Yolo and now
just to demonstrate if I go back to my
projects in point and try to fetch all
the projects for my user it's going to
return an array with that project
created and so I can hit this a couple
of times to keep creating projects and
then when I try to fetch all the
products from a user notice that we have
like a 5 over 4 project returned let's
just go ahead and commit what we have
and then we can kind of just knock out
all the remaining project methods
okay so the last two methods we're going
to create on the project's controller is
going to be a create or I'm sorry not
create it's gonna be a delete in an
update method so let's go back to our
routes and let's go ahead and make a new
endpoint that takes a delete request and
this one is going to actually take a ID
so if I do project ID here in fact I'll
just keep it ID to keep it generic and
then we can call a destroy method and
again make sure the user is
authenticated before we hit this in
point so if we go back to our project
controller and then create a async
method called destroy it's going to take
it off in a request but let's kind of
step through what we need to do again we
need to fetch the user so whatever user
made the request get that user model
and then we need to get the project ID
that we declared here and the route so
to do that in adonis we could also
include another property called pram or
sorry params and that's going to give us
the query parameters and we need the ID
so if i do ID is equal to grams done ID
or again if we wanted to do object
deconstruction we do this
after we have the ID we want to fetch
the project that's associated with the
ID of a Const project equals to a weight
project dot find now find is a method
that you can use it pass in the IDE that
we want to find it's going to return the
project model so I'm just going to say
find ID that's going to return us the
project now at this point we don't want
any user to just potentially destroy
this model right we want to make sure
that the project we fetched actually has
access or the user that did call destroy
actually has access to the project right
so what we can do is we can just say
make sure that project user ID is equal
to user dot ID before we do anything in
this case I'm just gonna say not equal
and then if they're not equal to return
something to the user so here I'm going
to say response dot a return response
dot status of 403 basically return a 403
status code which is authentication or
authorization error status
if the project that we fetch does not
match the user that was asked in with
the GWT token but if we do have access
we're going to not hit that if statement
and underneath here we can just say
project delete and then we're going to
return the project that was deleted
let's just go ahead and save this and
try to test it out
so going back here notice that this user
has a bunch of different projects
associated with it so let me describe
project three and I'm going to go to the
delete request and tell it to delete
project three so after I run that it's
returning the project information that
was deleted and if I go back to my get
request how to fetch all the projects
notice that three does not exist in this
list anymore
so our delete method is working as
expected
before we move on something like this is
going to be copied and pasted a lot
throughout our application so I kind of
want to abstract that into a different
hope or service or something like that
so what we can do is I'm gonna make a
new folder inside an app called services
and I'm sure there's other ways to do
this my heart isn't sure I'm sure you
could use like providers as well
but for now I'm going to keep it simple
but I'm just going to make a new service
called authorization service
and inside that service I'm just gonna
make a class called authorization like a
type and that's gonna have a method
called verify permission which takes a
resource and it takes a user
the exact same thing as we did before I
say if the resource user ID is not equal
to the user ID we're going to throw some
new error and in a second I'm going to
actually use a real error here
now what we can do is back in our
project controller we can go to the top
and include that so I'm just say offer
is a ssin service is equal to use app
services authorization service and
instead of doing this if statement here
I'm just going to say authorization
service that verify permission project
user
so hopefully if everything works out
correctly if I were to run this with the
delete method and pass it ID 4 it should
still delete that resource and in this
case I got an exception let's see let's
see what that exception was verify
permission is not a function so I might
have spelled something wrong
verify permission
authorization service oh I forgot to
export at the bottom my bed so make sure
at the bottom I'm just going to export a
new authorization service here that we
can use it open now if I were to hit
this end point it delete it deleted this
project with an ID of four so everything
is still working as expected but if I
want to test if I had access to the
resource so let me just log in with a
different user so if you remember we
made a user of testing 3 let me grab a
token and update here
difficulties deleting this token huh
okay so we updated the environment to
have a
touken protesting three now I want to a
delete ID of one in two which if you
notice has a user ID of one but the
token that I'm set up with is not that
correct user so if I go back to delete
and try to delete project one we get
back an exception and in this case it
should be a very generic exception it
doesn't say anything but notice that
this is actually running now if I were
to go here and just print something else
and try to delete that again
that prints out invalid access so
something full and Adonis that I need to
point out is that when an exception is
thrown in your controller it's going to
return that exception to the user so I
don't need to have if statements and
like specify certain status codes in
return instead I could abstract that
into an exception again going back to a
really useful adonis CLI if I do Adonis
help notice that we can make an
exception here
so I'm gonna do Adonis May
exception help information on that this
one only takes a name so I'm gonna say
let's see authorization actually I'm
going to name it's invalid access into
valid access and that should make a new
exception called invalid access
exception inside this exceptions folder
so now that we have the invalid access
exception we could just write a custom
handler function which is going to take
in an error as the first argument and
then you can have access to the response
here and basically we just want to
return a response of a 403 status code
to the user a return response status of
4-3 and then I'm going to send it back
some JSON this as error 'invalid access
to resource
well so now then I save that so invalid
access exception is equal to use app
exceptions dots invalid access exception
instead of throwing new error we can
just throw our new exception here our
access the authorization server should
be returning that exception and then
when this exception fires from Adonis
it's going to return a 403 status if I
go back and hit that endpoint notice we
get a 403 for a bit forbidden and we get
invalid access to resource and this kind
of helps us clean up our controllers so
that we don't have a bunch of if
statements to check if something is
defined or if a user exists so another
exception I want to catch is for
whatever reason if let's say Project was
not defined so they give us ID of a
thousand this is going to be null here
which is going to hit this function and
probably throw a 500 error right
so let's just go ahead an other
exception called resource not exist
the inside verify permission
if we were to just check and say if
resource was not defined let's just
throw a new invalid our sorry resource
not exist exception and there might be a
better way to do this that's already
like built into the Donna's framework
but this seems to work for now and then
of course inside of that exception we
just copy the handler that we had in our
previous exception paste it here and we
want this to be a for for and say the
resource did not exist
oh so I'll save that one I'll go back
and I'll try like out of a thousand
click send and notice that we get back a
four or four not found the resource to
not exist
that is a really high-level overview of
exceptions and how you could handle them
to return custom status codes to your
requests let's go ahead and commit what
we have now and move on to the last one
which is going to be update
exceptions
my code and get back to a nice state
just to continue working
okay so the last route that we want to
add for projects would be an update
route
so here if I say Ralph dot patch and
again that's gonna be Project /id and
we're gonna say update that's going to
also need the auth middleware but we
created our route let's go to our
controller and create our action so I'm
going to say update auth request params
very similar code we could probably pull
this out into like helper functions so
we don't copy and paste code everywhere
but since this is just a simple tutorial
well I'm not going to do that again I'm
fetching the user from the auth helper
function I'm fetching the ID that we
want to update I'm fetching the project
that we want to update
I'm going to verify that we have access
to that project and that that project
also exists and then finally what we
want to do is we want to fill in like we
did before
in this case I'm going to do merge so
project that merge and I'm gonna say
merge it with the request of the title
the only grab the title that's passed
into the quest and then I want to save
that the project that's save and then I
want to return the project this is kind
of a new method that we saw basically
it's gonna take from the body of the
request just grab me the title so if
someone were to pass in a bunch of
different properties I just want the
title here and then I want to merge that
into the project and save it and return
at this point let's just go back and
fetch all the projects that do exist on
this user is remember we deleted a bunch
we don't have any so let me just create
a new one
go back fetch it well so we have a
project as ID 5 which belongs to a user
2 let's change the title to Gigi so if I
go to my patch in point let me can a
patch request to project slash five we
want to change the title to Gigi so if I
were to send this now this should work
okay and it did so we've updated the
title to be Gigi if I go back and try to
fetch the projects associated with my
user the title is down Gigi okay so
update is working as expected now so we
have our four main crud methods we have
create fetch update and destroy we don't
necessarily need to show at this point
because I don't think we need to fetch a
single project in the UI but we could
always come back and add that if we need
to so let's go ahead and commit that so
let's say add update in point
then we can move on to our tasks
okay so for our tasks we're gonna be
we're going to need to create a new
model again we can go here and say make
model and then we're gonna pass it tasks
with - M so it creates our migration
scripts and let's move to our migration
scripts and just add whatever we need
for the the tasks
entry
so task is going to have a title and
it's also going to be associated with a
project so I'm just going to copy those
and instead of user ID interesting
project ID and that's going to be in the
table projects refers to ID this looks
good and then instead of title I'm just
going to say description those tasks
should be set up correctly and now I
need to go into my models and very
similar to how we did before I'm gonna
go to our user model I'm going to copy
and paste this is a task has many our
sorry I project as many tasks so here
I'm going to go
asks and a project has many tasks
inside of our tasks I'm going to say a
task has one or belongs to a project go
ahead and say that I should be able to
run my migration scripts at this point
which will create our tasks table and we
should be able to actually use our lucid
models to start manipulating with that
table
okay so let me go ahead and just close
out of some of these so it's not so
overwhelming like a step back what are
we doing so we want the ability for
users to create new tasks
and because of the way a task is set up
you can't really have a task unless you
have a project in which it associates
with so I'm just going to add a new
endpoint here called projects of /id
slash tasks so a user can post a task to
a project
and of course here we're going to say
tasks controller instead of project
controller and that's going to be a
crate method and of course we need to
make sure we're authenticated here as
well
so
I'll set up let's go to our task
controller which you don't have created
yet so if I go make controller and then
pass that task
that'll create us a new controler file
or our HTTP requests and inside here we
need an async create method
and this one's going to be very similar
to the project create method so let's
probably just go ahead and create our
copy and paste all the code that was
under our project create method if I go
to project I go to create I'm going to
copy this code and then of course make
sure you include the things up here that
you need so we're going to need project
and we're probably going to need tasks
so I'm gonna include project and task
okay so when we create a task remember
that in the prams we have that project
ID
so you know I'll comment this out for
now so we can just kind of reference it
but first of all yes we're gonna need
the user so let's just grab that user Oh
why that happen autocomplete and then we
need to grab the description from the
request so a description of request of
all
and then we need the project ID Oh ID
from prams
remember we don't have of--there so
let's bring off bring in request
let's bring in params
we're going to need to fetch the project
so cost project is equal to a weight
project fine by ID so that will fetch us
the project
we want to verify that the user has
access to the project though I'm just
going to go here copy and paste this
authorization service stuff
you
then we verify that the project the user
has access to the project
so if you remember before when we
created a project and we associate it
with a user kind of the same deal here
so what we need to do is we need to say
create a task the mistake Const task is
equal to new task instantiate a new
Lucid instance model and then I'm going
to say task got fill in a pass a
description and then I need to associate
that task with a project some say wait
project got tasks dot save the task and
I want to return that task back to the
user
so nothing nothing new here at all is
just kind of a matter of
doing a little bit more extra code
because we need to grab the project and
then we need to associate the task with
the project and then all the other stuff
we've seen before fetching the user
fetching the description from the
parameters are the ID from the parameter
is the description from the request
that's all said and done the past
so
while we're here let's just go ahead and
create an index method so we can fish
all the tasks associated with the
project so we can easily test and see
what's going on so I'm going to add a
another route Auld it on the tasks in
point and that's going to call the index
method and that again is going to be
indicated here
so going back here I'm going to say make
a new method called a sink of index
that's going to take off and request
you
and very similar we need the user
we're gonna need Rams as well actually
though in fact let me just copy all this
and then delete what we don't need
we fetch the user we don't need the
description doesn't write really
creating or updating anything so remove
that we don't need to make a new task so
remove that you don't need to fetch or
associate tasks so remove that
cool so we if the user if the project ID
we fetch the project you verify you
chose access to the project in we just
need to return oh wait
project tasks dot fetch
so returned all the tasks that are
associated with a particular project ID
assuming that the user has access to
that project let's try to test out these
two methods and hopefully everything
works out
you
so again let's create a new project
just that we have something to work with
and then that project ID is a six so if
I go to tasks here we want to be able to
post a new task to that project ID so
I'm going to put project IDs six here
I'm going to pass a description of hello
make sure my headers are set up and they
are so hopefully if I click send this
will get added to the database and it
did the now project ID of six has a
hello task if I do it again I should
have two tasks but then to fetch the
tasks I'm going to click on the get
request URL that I have saved here I'm
going to change this to get the project
ID of six tasks make sure the header set
up and it is but when I click send here
I should get two tests back and we do so
awesome those two endpoints we just
created are now working and really that
then it take much time at all to create
so we're kind of coming close to
wrapping this up so let me just go ahead
and commit what we have so let's say
tasks index and create and let's move on
to the last two things that we need for
a task obviously we need to be able to
update and delete tasks right so let's
go back to here let's make a route dot
delete on tasks of ID
I'll make that a destroy call and make
sure you have middleware and let's just
go ahead and make the other one while
we're at it here so we need a patch
request and we need to be able to update
the task so for deleting a task it's
going to be very similar to deleting a
project so I'm just going to go to the
destroy method copy and paste that into
my S controller
and kind of modify it as needed
so here again we fetch the user we need
the task ID or we need the project ID I
mean
actually no we don't we don't need the
project ID so this is
to be the task ID here we need to fetch
the task
we need to verify at some point that the
project that the task is associated with
the user has access to so here we need
to say project
you
our cost project is equal to tasks that
project fetch and then we can check that
the project the task is associated with
the user has access to if they do all we
need to do is say a way to test delete
and then we can just return that task
here
so everything here should be okay let's
go ahead and implement the last method
which is update so just copy and paste
some code
we're gonna need probably similar code
here again we fetch the user with the
project ID here or sorry get the task ID
fetch the project that's associated with
the task verify the users essence to the
project and then instead of deleting
here we need to do that whole task dot
urghhh
and we're gonna say requests only and we
only care about the description in this
case
you
in fact I forgot to have a completed so
when you're in the UI and you're
clicking and marking tasks as completed
we want to have yet another boolean
called completed on that task object so
we're going to need to go back to our
migration scripts and kind of update
that
but so let's finish up this task
controller really quick and then let's
go back to our migration scripts we go
to migrations I got a task and here I
could just say boolean of beaten
hmm so a cool thing you can do in Adonis
is if we look at the migrations again
there should be a refresh so if I do
Adonis migration colon refresh that's
going to drop and reset all of my
migrations and it's going to rerun them
all again so that basically we're
creating this completed thing we're
adding this completed tea
column to our table
you can also do a rollbacks if you
wanted to or reset our stuff or you
precious pretty good because it just
rolled back rolls back everything and
then reruns them so now our table should
have a tasks
sorry now our database should have a
tasks table with a completed boolean
column in addition to the other ones
ahead before
so at this point since we roll back it
probably deleted all of her data so we
need to go back and register a user
and then we need to fetch this token and
update our authorization header here
we need to create a project make sure we
get that project ID of one let's go
ahead and create a task on project 1
that's the projects in the tasks just to
make sure that everything is set up as
it should be
it's a completed null awesome
description of hello but we want to test
out that we can first of all update that
task
so this is task of ID one
let's just check that we can update the
description to patch and completed to
pulse so if I send that we're getting
back an error so let's go ahead and look
at the error here
find module controllers tasks controller
that's just because it's not tasks
controller it should be tasks
I named that incorrectly so that's my
bad let me save that go back and hit
this in point
and now we're getting an invalid access
to resource
or o3 for bin see
you
[Music]
you
okay so looking back at the task
controller let's look at the update
method and figure out why this is saying
invalid access
and so we're fetching the user getting
the ID hitting the task getting the
project
verifying the user has access to the
project so what we could do here just
start printing stuff out so project dot
new JSON I could do tasks to JSON I also
do user dot to Jason and make sure all
these kind of line up as we'd expect
them to
you
you
um let's pace this and see what's going
on Roger got to Jason is not a function
okay
you
you
so instead of saying to Jason let's just
print these out so we have a task which
has an idea of one project idea of one
we have a user which has an ID of one
and we have a
where the project go oh
so this will get you every time make
sure you always have a weight in front
of your acing calls if you don't this is
just gonna be a promise and then it
never thought nothing's really gonna
work as intended let me say that I want
to make sure I had that updated
correctly as
you
okay sorry about that one let's see if
this will finally work
so I think it finally patched that task
with description patch two completed
false so if I were to go back and try to
get that task see that we have completed
is zero and patched is the description
now and then finally we want to test if
we can delete a task so if we go to the
delete method and tell it to delete task
of ID one
look send notice that it returns the
task back to us and if we try to fetch
it again it's not there
so a little bit of hiccups along the way
you know stuff I forgot to do in this
tutorial but
overall I think we're done building out
a REST API they didn't take too much
time as once you get a couple of routes
going it's as simple as copy pasting and
changing around and then as time goes on
you'll notice that these crud methods
are basically the same for every single
resource so you could probably create a
helper method that decorates these
controllers that kind of does this logic
for you
but for the sake of this tutorial let's
not dive into refactoring or do anything
like that basically we have a way for
users to register log in great projects
great tasks update those tasks and
projects and delete them and stuff so
we're at a good State now that we can
commit what we have wrap this up and
move on to the View j/s tutorial
all right so now we're going to get
started in the second section of this
tutorial which is the view J as fronting
and very similar to the last section I'm
kind of just going to rate it as I go
and explain what I'm doing if you feel
lost at any time feel free to pause and
go look up the view documentation so to
get started with building out the UI you
move over to the view CLI github repo
the latest version they have out is view
version 3 beta 10 I'm going to install
version beta 9 because I'm getting
issues with tin but you don't want to
use version 3 if you want to use the old
you CLI - I'm not sure how how well that
will translate to this tutorial so in
this tutorial I'm using version 3
if I copy that and go ahead and just
paste it in my terminal and put ad
version 3 0 0 beta 9 that's going to
install the correct you CLI that I need
to kind of demo awesome so now that that
is completed we can simply run view
create and then type the name of the
folder or project you want to create so
on this click in this case we're going
to do client we want to create a client
folder that has our stuff and after you
do that it's going to kind of walk you
through a couple of questions as to what
you want to use to set up your project
so I'm going to do manual select
features just to make sure that we're
not instantly something that we don't
want so I want the router I want to view
X and I'm just using the arrow on my
keyboard in the space button to select
stuff linter would be nice
and CSS preprocessors I guess would be
nice I'll hit enter I'm going to say use
sass
and I'm going to use the Airbnb config
this is like the lentor options
a slant on save be good enough
kada config file I should be okay
so after you select all the stuff that
you want it's going to go ahead and just
create your client folder and initialize
all your different view stuff that might
take a while because it's probably
installing a lot of different packages
so now that bat is finally done running
we have a view app over here which I'm
not going to go through all these files
just start developing on it and I'll
explain what I'm doing as we go through
but before we get started there's a
couple of extra dependencies I want to
install now so that we don't have to
worry about installing them later
so if we look at what we currently have
we really only have three dependencies
view view router view X but there's a
couple more that we're going to need so
I'm gonna do yarn add and then the first
one we're going to need is Axios and
that's for doing HTTP requests and
whatnot
I like having lo - just in case we're
going to need beautify and that is a
material like framework or library to
kind of style your components and build
up your app and then two other helpful
libraries I uses view X persisted State
and that's so I can store my view X
state into local storage and load it
back when the roam tab opens up and the
filing of UX router sync well that's
going to go ahead and install all those
dependencies and update my package JSON
with those
now that that's all done like I ran it
in the wrong directory so let me just
delete these why don't we go into the
client directory and rerun that so to
start off what I'm going to do is I'm
going to open up the source folder and
inside here we have a main JSO which is
kind of where everything gets
initialized and created for view it's
also where you need to like include a
lot of your dependencies and set them up
so I'm going to do that with those
dependencies we just Yarn installed so
starting off I'm going to include
import sink
from view ex router or sink I'm going to
import it beautify
beautify
let's see what else we might need
I think that's kind of all we need for
right now but what we can do is just
include both of those or run them so
they sync the store with the router
view to use beautify
you
and I think that
a good start
winters complaining that you should come
at the very top because they are
actually
packages and not from my local files
like these are yeah so I'll do em p.m.
run serve
that's going to open up a browser and
point it to your view webpage in just a
second so here we go we have our view UI
loaded and running
and if we hit did everything right we
should have those additional plugins
like beautify and the view X router sync
it's set up
and just to verify that I'm going to go
to my view plug in here so that's this
is a chrome plugin that you can install
or using view X and debugging up so as I
change routes we should see our route
change in our state if you see here we
have our routes state here is at that
slash a belt and before it was at slash
this sink command is working fine a
little bit more refactoring I like to
put my store in a store folder so I'm
gonna say store I'm going to copy that
into there
but I rename this to index
of course if you do that make sure you
include it here so instead of actually
that should work as is
so a little bit more setup I'm going to
look at the store I'm going to include
that persist state package that we
brought in I'm going to say import
create persisted state from view X
persisted eight
that we use it
so to use that basically you just need
to declare a plugins array for your
store so down here I can say plugins an
attribute which has a create persistent
state object inside that array and save
that let's see we're getting a error
here something is still trying to load
storage is and that's probably in my
main
[Music]
is coming from there
okay for whatever reason I need to do
/index here typically be imported smart
enough to just find the index file I'm
not sure why I need to do that but hey
we're gonna run into issues as we're
making this UI so the more issues that
I'd be plugged apparently the better it
is for a tutorial so let's go ahead and
actually get started on building out
some functionality we did some initial
setup some of it might have not made too
much sense it's kind of boilerplate
setup so really don't have to worry
about it too much unless you're planning
to do the exact same thing that I'm
doing with this tutorial so starting off
let's go ahead and try to start using
beautify to build out some header or
something like that at the top it's kind
of nice to have a top header up here
where we have things we can click so the
first thing I'm going to do is just load
up the beautify Docs so view 2phi go to
their Doc's here
we're going to be using this throughout
our tutorial to kind of figure out what
components we can use to build up our
application
so first off they say in order to set up
your app with beautify you need to make
sure that you have everything wrapped in
a VF component an example down here it
looks like this so if i just go back to
my app view which is like the main part
of this what I need to do is just inside
my template I can say V app and then of
course wrap everything in that
at that point we should be okay and
we're all gonna refactor all this second
so since we did this setup let's just go
ahead and come out what we have so now
so all these files aren't just like
green and kind of confusing so I'll say
initial view set up go ahead and commit
that go back to my tree view
so let's get back on track kind of
jumping around what we need to do here
is we need to build out a beautify top
navigation so that we can use it in our
application so if we go back to the dock
so let's look at the components that
they have
something called a toolbar Papa click
toolbars
give us some examples of the toolbars
that they have how to use them so I'll
click the code to get an example and
basically I'm just going to copy and
paste this into my app for now
for all this stuff we can just kind of
for now but we're probably going to get
rid of it so if I save this file and go
back to my view app
notice that the styles are all messed up
and that's mainly because I forgot to do
an additional step in our setup which
was I need to include the beautify CSS
so if I go back to that main J's file
you need to make sure that we import the
beautify projects CSS so I'm going to do
import beautify dist
beautify that mend CSS go ahead and save
this
and we're going to run to an error
because we haven't included
actually this is just a linting error
it'll let me go
figure out how to fix this this is
trailing spaces are not allowed we must
have a trailing space somewhere which is
right here so I'm going to go ahead and
just remove that and save it
so that loaded correctly if I go back to
my app awesome we have the beautify CSS
in the top now except for now the menu
is messed up if you look to the example
their toolbar has a little hamburger
thing that you can click ours just says
menu so another thing that we forgot to
set up it'd be nice if like there's
already project that kind of settle this
stuff up for you but I guess there's not
so do it by hand
so what we need to do at this point is
we need to go into the public file and
I'm sure you can also import this in
Maine but the way I did is I went to the
public index.html file and in this file
it's just a typical file that you know
your app is going to be injected into
but we want to include the material
icons so if I go up here and just go
ahead and just include that link through
the material icon style sheet so this is
the material icon that we need to
include just go ahead and save this at
hamburger menu should appear now
and it does cool cool cool okay so
making some slow and steady progress
let's go ahead and try to modify this to
customize it to be kind of something we
want so first of all I don't want the
hamburger menu for now and these links
over here need to be something that's
actually related to what we're building
since we're building a to-do list
application really all we need is like a
register or logout button and maybe a
button to see all your projects or
something and then maybe also like a
link to see this YouTube video once I
host it so let's go back here and let's
go to our app view those all these
and then in here
for our title I want to save you to do
but and save that and just see that
reflected here
awesome I kind of want to add some color
to this so I'm just going to say color
is equal to green
and I want to make it a dark attribute
so that the text is white and then I
want to say fixed so that it always
stays on the top of my browser so you
notice here as I scroll down it's still
fixed to the top so awesome we have a
view of you to do toolbar green fixed go
ahead and get rid of that am burger icon
I really want that
is gone
as we need to add a button so we can
click our projects LV toolbar items
that's going to be a class of hidden for
small I should I'm not going to add any
class of that
buttons and stuff in a V tool bar
toolbar items and inside here you add
your buttons so say V button close that
off and this button is going to say
projects
they make this one line say that
cool so it looks kind of messed up but
we're going to fix that in a second
button if I were to say make that flat
save that that's going to make it a flat
button so it looks a little bit better
and we also kind of want an icon so I'm
going to do V icon
you
I want to put a playlist ad check
economy
let me just make this into a new line so
let's read
well so we have a button that says
projects and it has a little icon to the
left of it so people can understand that
that's like your main view for seeing
your projects and to-do list items one
thing I want to fix really quick is this
margin here that's needs to be added so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
to that title
here and I was going to add a class of
mr - 4 which means margin-right 4 and
that's gonna push that button over to
the right some so it looks a little bit
cleaner
and then later we can come along and add
like routing here to the header if we
need to but let's finish off with adding
a couple of more so we're going to need
a register button we're going to need a
logout button
again button
you
and I also want to include some icons on
those I just like putting icons next to
my buttons although I'm not sure if
that's good UX or not so for register
I'm going to say count box or login I
want to do a fingerprint and then for a
logout I want to say exit to app
and then also I want to add a button
that says how this was made just
basically there's going to be a link to
this YouTube video
you
awesome so we have a bunch of different
buttons and of course as we go on we're
gonna hide them show them depending on
if the user was logged in or whatnot
um one thing I do want to fix really
quick is that all these buttons are
really close to the text so I'm just
gonna add a little bit of margin to all
of these buttons here so wherever I see
flat I'm just gonna say class of margin
right of to save that and notice that
all of our buttons actually I think I
should have used them padding right
so pr2 is a way to add padding the stuff
mr2 is a way to add like margin of stuff
okay edit it to the wrong stuff
yeah my bad my bad I added it to the
wrong thing I should have instead added
it to the V icons here so if I describe
both the icons and just do class of
margin right too
that she make it look a little bit
better so sorry I'm kind of recording
this early in the morning I'm still like
trying to wake up and I make a lot of
mistakes but hopefully I'm still
explaining this decently okay so let's
move on refactoring this a little bit
because you see here this AB dot view
file could potentially get pretty big
right now I'm already hitting like 30
lines and it's good to kind of D couple
your components so it's easier to
understand so it would make sense to
pull this out into a separate component
right because these buttons down here
like when we have our content the router
view doesn't need to know about the
toolbar header
so to do that what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna first copy and paste this
in fact I'm gonna cut it
and I'm going to make a new component
called bull bar
and then I'm gonna scaffold that out and
I'm gonna paste that HTML inside of that
template
you
go ahead and save that and then in my
app dot view I could just include that
toolbar after I import it so here I'm
going to go ahead and add a script
JavaScript and then I'm going to import
you
created
at slash components slash bullbar vu
then in here we want to simply do
components
and that's going to be an object with
the name of our component
you
my hair says we're missing a semicolon
so let's go ahead and :
make sure my linting is all working
trailing space inside of my
HTML so let's fix that really
you
a missing michael bars in extent
okay so all of those are passing now so
the last part or step I need to do is
once I've imported that toolbar into my
app table view you just go up here and
simply do the toolbar
notice here the toolbar is still
displaying if I were to go back to my
code and just comment that out to
demonstrate the toolbar will disappear
all right so the next component a review
I want to work on is going to be their
register view so that we can actually
register users so let's go ahead and get
started on that if we go to our toolbar
notice that we had a register button if
we wanted that to actually do something
when we clicked it you could simply add
the property to and pass it the URL we
want to redirect the user to when they
click on the button so I'm going to say
to slash register
at this point we don't have a register
view or route created I'm gonna go my
router Nijs file and I'm gonna create
one
let's go ahead and copy and paste what's
there already
make this register
you
register component
and again we don't have a register
component created so what we need to do
is pretend like we have one created in
our views folder and I will go here and
just go ahead and create a new register
dot view file inside of this and go
ahead and scaffold that up well so now
at this point actually I'm just going to
say I'll make this h1 I'm gonna say
register just make sure that we can view
something but if I go back to my UI I
should be able to click on that register
and the top nav it's going to redirect
us to that register view
case it's not let's kind of investigate
what's going on
[Music]
you
going back to the toolbar
and it's because I put it on the wrong
element I should have put it on the
button not the V icon so that's my bad
let me go back here at it to V button
go back
register now and notice that it
redirects us to a slot register in point
you
anyway so now that we have the register
in point a register route let's go ahead
and add a couple things to that view
such as you know a login button a user
name they can enter in a password form
so we don't need the toolbar at this
point we're done with the router done
with app so inside the register
component what we need to do is let's go
ahead and make this a if for now we can
come back and change that to probably
like something that's more layout
specific and we need to create
let's say a title of h1 so it's going to
say register and then we're going to
need a input box and using beautify
there's one called B text field some say
B text field and the properties that you
can pass the V text field include the
label I'm going to say email and to say
the value so we'll leave that blank for
now
I'm just a label email placeholder
equals email
and we'll come back in a second and add
actual other values to it
and of course we need one for password
this is going to be a type of password
and when I made I'm gonna make it
autocomplete equals false are actually
equals new password so that Chrome
doesn't automatically fill it in with
stuff so we have two text fields wave
email and password here and then we also
need like a register button I'm gonna
add a B button
and in that be button what we can do is
give it a color so I'm gonna say color
green I'm going to give it dark so that
the text is white
inside here we can say register
you
go ahead and give it an icon since I
like to give icons next my buttons
so a good icon that we could use here
includes a account icon so let's do a
count circle save that go back we have a
register button here now
I so we're making some progress one
thing I'll notice is that no I don't
want this to expand the entire page with
if we were to go back to our component
instead of using a div let's do an
actual container so I'll say B container
and then make sure we update the closing
element and then inside the container
you can do a B layout
rowrr app and again these are just
beautify built-in components for layout
container I have a layout saying that
everything should be in a row
and then I'm saying inside that row I
want the road to be with of six on a
small and then push everything to the
right by 3 I'll explain that one second
so let me say that and now notice here
you have everything kind of centered
here so basically we go back to these
attributes I told it to give it a width
of six basically it's going to divide
your page into twelve different columns
I'm saying this is going to be six
columns of width and then I want to push
it over three columns so this is column
one two three starts at comma four with
the six and then we have column seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve
you
utilize that here if I go and look at
this we have a
the six columns here and then were
pushed over a three if you notice the
three is adding a padding right here
this should allow us to when we resize
the page still going to stay in the
center
what kind of gives us the benefit of
responsive websites without having to do
much work but we're not focusing on
making a responsive website so let's
keep on moving on and try to implement
the actual registration login
functionality full so now we're getting
into the actual logic of this
registration page and we need to first
start figuring out how to bind stuff to
view X so for anyone who's not really
familiar with the UX basically it's a
place where you have all of your
application logic stored in a single
place and then your components are going
to update that state and fire off
actions and mutations to change the
state I guess the benefit of that is
it's very easy to understand like where
all your application is like how does
your application change over time well
it kind of debug and show you how useful
that is in a second but again let's just
implement it I'll kind of explain it
along the way so we need to first of all
go into our store and let's make a new
file called authentication
be named whatever you want does really
matter
inside that authentication file we want
to export a new object which is going to
be like a store module so I'm going to
say this is gonna be namespace to true
state in here is gonna have some things
we can kind of add on to it in a second
and before we start adding on to this
let's go ahead and make sure that we
include that module here in our main
store so up here you're able to do
modules and include a list of modules
here so I want to include a
authentication module
which of course we have an importer yet
some say import Asian from
authentication
that's basically going to hole in this
default object here and put it directly
into my modules object here so then I'll
be able to access it with my mutations
and actions and setters and stuff from
my view components again this probably
won't make sense until we start using it
so just a recap we made a module and we
include it in our store so let's go back
to our module what do we actually need
to store interstate so if we were to
look at a register component basically
we need to store when they update their
email that they're about to submit
when they update their password I so two
things that we know that we need to keep
track of so let's keep track of a
register email and beam all by default
in register S word that's also in beam
all
so in order to kind of bind these to
change these we need to first make a
couple of mutations so if I go here I'm
going to add another property called
mutations and inside this mutations
property we can just define different
functions that it will affect our state
here so I'm going to say set register
email that's going to stake or take a
state and also a an email as a payload
and then we need the same thing for set
register password
the state thought register email is
email same thing here
register password is equal to password
you
I think this is because um we spun this
up using Airbnb easiest excellent and
they typically use react but we need to
actually be able to do this so let's go
to IES Lind file
[Music]
and let's add some rules so I'm gonna
say rules the one that's giving us
issues is no pram reassign and I'm going
to turn that off for now so that we
don't get that error
and unfortunately when you change that
Uslan file you have to rerun your serve
command I think there's a couple of
other ones you might a couple of other
rules we might add and disable mainly
because you know everyone has their own
opinions of how their code should look
and I have my own or so
let's let that reload here
well so a little recap we have two
properties on our authentication module
state called a register email and
register password and then we have two
mutations which we can use to change
those so with that being said how do we
actually bind our view component to
change those if we go back to our
register view file what we need to do is
first import our a couple of helper
functions from view X so I'm first going
to do import map state and I'm going to
do map mutations
from Buicks
and to use these basically you just kind
of
decorate your component object with
following these functions so for an
example if we wanted the ability to call
set password or set registration email
or one of these we need to map the
mutations to our object so I'll just say
map
mutations
actually first of all I need to bind
that to a method so I'm gonna say
methods is an object and then I want to
map some mutations to that that's
function where I can pass it the module
name so I'll think tation and then I
pass it the methods I actually wanted to
app so this is the first function that
we want to map and this is the second
function we
so basically all this is doing is saying
that this component is going to have
these two methods that I can call so up
here I can call those like whenever I
click on register or whenever I change
text in here I can simply just call
those methods here and then also what we
want to do is we want to grab in our
computed state values here so that we
can set a register email password when
that view loads so up here I'm going to
say computed which is another property
you can use on your view component
instead of map mutations I'm going to
say map state again pass it the module
name
we want to map and then pass it our
state that we want to map in in this
case I'm going to say register email and
register password
you
all right so if everything worked well I
should be able to start using these
so the first thing I want to do is I
want to go up here and I want to bind
the value of my text fields to its
corresponding state value so I'm gonna
say value is equal to register email
you
- buying this text field - whatever the
state value is down here and I wanted
the same thing for a register password
so I'm gonna go down here and say bind
this to register password
and let's just demonstrate what we are
actually doing here so if I go back to
this view the register view notice that
email and password are not set to
anything and that's because in our state
I go to the authentication module
actually clear on my localstorage I
think it has stuff
okay so in our thent ocation module we
have a register email and register
password state and those are both null
but if I come back to here and say hello
and this changes the world and save this
notice that when this page refreshes
I think it's because I'm using
:
one second that kind of show you what
I'm doing I need to actually disable
this plug-in because this is trying to
load my state from the store which is
not what we want to do to be able to
demonstrate this
sometimes I hate me it's Lent
there we go
sorry about that basically I change this
to initial state of these two properties
to be hello world and notice that our
inputs are set to those now
I'm gonna keep this plugin disabled for
right now so it doesn't cause more
issues back into enable in a second
so again if I change the
and a do to the end of it when this page
loads this input is going to fetch that
value from the store and just populate
it
so that's kind of the first step we
bound these text fields to the state
now the second part is we need to bind
what happens when we input into this in
update our store so if I do at input so
basically whenever someone changed the
values of this
text field
is just call
set register email down here
and then same thing for the password
let's say set register password
so now when I type you'll notice that
it's firing off a view X mutation down
here authentication slash set register
email and as that's changing it's
updating our state but and another cool
thing I can show is we can travel back
in time to all the different values of
our state so if I wanted to go back to
my app first loaded notice that it's
going to load my initial store values
here and that's reflected in our UI and
that kind of I can kind of step through
what happened over time with my
component and this is really useful for
debugging and understanding what's going
on with your application
let's go back to our code and try to
figure out what else is remaining so we
had the ability to type into the email
and password we're updating our store
with the corresponding values now what
we want to do is when the user clicks
register we want to fire off a view X
action to kind of hit that register in
point we're created on our previous
tutorial section so on this button I'm
going to add an @ click call back
register method which we have an
included yet so if I go down here now
and just pretend that the authentication
has a register action we say map actions
identification bring in that register
action and of course we are missing this
so we need to put it up here
if we go back to our authentication
module we need to just simply add in
actions and say register is going to
take um
[Music]
his register need there
do object construction and just grab the
commit function and also grab the state
so now we're getting into doing actual
HTTP requests to our server which is
running
so in this particular case we want to
grab the register email and password and
we want to do a post request to our
register endpoint so before we get too
far ahead of ourselves I want to make a
new component called HTTP ijs so I'm
going to do HTTP j/s and inside here
we're going to export a function which
is going to return a new Axios object so
I'm saying co-create and we haven't
included that so let's just do that
really quick
we also probably want the store because
I'm going to put the base URL in the
store
you
and before we go further with
implementing this go to our store and
just add a a Cu RL and set that equal to
API
I think I should slash API
so in this HTTP file we're going to
create an access object and we're going
to set the base URL let me say base URL
is equal to store dot state base URL
you
and then we want to say give it a
timeout of like one second so if request
doesn't finish in a second time it out
hmm
and that should be good for right now
should we had our semicolons this is
another one I do not like so I'm going
to disable that style
I go back to my es Lintz
just get rid of that
make sure you reset that
you can now go into our authentication
action that we're trying to create
import this HTTP function so if we can
create an Axios module so up here I'm
going to import HTTP from HTTP now we
have the ability to call that function
so here I'm just gonna say
returned HTTP POST
the reason we can call that post is
because on this Axios object it has
different methods such as get post patch
put delete stuff like that and we want
to make a post request to our auth slash
register in point
and then we need to pass it some data in
the body payload I'm going to say email
is equal to state dot register email
and then password is equal to state that
register password
I'm going to make it so the moment we
call this action I just want to reset my
username and password back to but it was
so I'm gonna say commit set registration
actually um we need commit at this point
so let me just save that show you what
happens when we run this method
so remember we already bound this
register button to make send off an
action event so if I click it or
actually getting an error now so let's
see those localhost:8080 /ss register is
not found in the main issue here is if
you remember we are hosting our API
import 3 333 this is trying to make a
request to e2 80 another cool thing you
can do is we just want to pretend that
the API and the UI are going to be
hosted on the same port same domain
under a proxy so if we go back to our
main folder where we have our client
folder I can make a new file called view
dock config is an inside here if I just
export an object that has dev server has
a property and I tell it to proxy slash
API I can give it a target until a to
point to my adonis server on port 3 3 3
3 goes off all the
and I think I might need to restart my
server this is basically just doing a
proxy whenever I do a request to slash
API it's going to point to a different
port on this machine and you config
dodge is is automatically kind of loaded
in we are using the view CLI so let's go
back to our UI when that refreshes let's
click the register button again
you
to register here
so if you see here we try to make a
request to 8080 slash a P I such office'
register the request payload is this
hello yo password is world
and the server did not respond within a
second but let's just see if that was a
fluke
and it doesn't seem like it was so let's
look at her server maybe her server is
actually crashing for some reason let me
go to my server folder and go to my
controller or I'm trying to register and
let me just make sure I'm hitting this
so say console dot log hello world
you
so we are hitting this end point I think
it's just taking a little bit longer
than a second to register our user so
let's go back to our HTTP change this
time out to five seconds instead and
let's try to hit at end point again
you
and we're getting the error I guess
saying that the user already exists and
it does
I'll do hello with an exclamation mark
try to register that user instead
[Music]
okay this one actually works so we got
back that token which we're gonna need
the store in our store at some point but
right now you saw there's no cuz I'm
feedback for the user when we registered
and what we want to do is a store the
token in the store and then we want to
redirect the user to a different view go
back to this get rid of the hello world
and just start that
hmm go back to review CLI
Oh some these files
okay so first thing we wanted to do is
we said we wanted to store the token
inside the store so if I do a dot then
you can grab data that's returned from
the Axios request
and then inside this data we could
simply do commit set token data token of
course we don't have a commit our
mutation called set token so let's add
one will say set token we get the state
we get to token and we need to set state
that token is equal to token and we also
don't have a token define our state so
let's go up here and say token is equal
to null
and also let's make sure we include
commits up here so we can run the
command
so let's try this see what happens if we
were to register with a new user that we
haven't done before
a click register notice that it fires
off the set token mutation and now in
our state we have a token set
so that's step one step two is we need
to change our router location so we need
to first import that router so import
router from dot dot slash router just to
import this file here and then if you
want to dynamically change the route
that wrong we do router dot push I'm
going to say go to the route
let's try registering with yet another
one so I'll just say hello click
register and notice that it redirected
us when we successfully logged in so a
couple of other things we want to do is
what if there was a login error right
what if the user tried to log in and it
was incorrect so we should probably
display some sort of registration error
on this page so to do that we're going
to need yet another store variable
called a register error
maybe know by default we want a mutation
to be able to set register error
you
you
and then in a registered IBEW file
we want to add a new alert probably add
it right above the register button so
I'll say be alert
and that component and I'm gonna give it
a couple of properties so I give it type
of error and I want to give it a value
of error I shall say register error
so basically if register error is
defined it should show up this alert and
notice register error we haven't brought
in so we need to go back down here to
methods and make sure we map the state
here I'm going to map the register error
states and I also want to just go ahead
and say actually we don't need to map
any mutations here
so right now that's not going to show up
regardless because we don't have a way
to actually check
or we don't have anything setting
register error so let's go back to our
action and what we want to do in our
action is if there is some type of error
so if I do dot catch I want to
the register error isms they commit that
register error
I want to say invalid registration
formation
and of course you can get more specific
I think you could probably catch the
actual error
and do something with it actually
instead I'm gonna say an error has
occurred of trying
you
all righty so
fully this works if we go back and try
to register this exact same user that
should already exist in the database you
get an error back and right now the
error is not displaying anything
so to debug this let's look we sent off
a mutation to set register error that
changed our authentication modules
register error store State or whatever
is called state to a string before
whatever reason we're not displaying
that in our alert
oh this is because I forgot to actually
render the X
so if you read through the beautified
docks alert this value is just going to
display it if this is true or defined
and then not display it if it's false
but you actually need to render
something inside here so make sure you
do the mustache and it'll bar stuff to
register to display your text
cool so now says an error has occurred
trying to create your account if I try
to create it again with something that
doesn't have an error it's going to
redirect us
and then one thing I'm going to do is
every time we try to register I'm just
going to commit null by reset that back
to nothing from our registration error
well so I think we're like most of being
done if not we are done with this
register view I think the last thing I
want to do is once you're registered I
want to hide a couple of these things in
the top toolbar and if you're not logged
in I want to show them so let's add
something new that we haven't seen yet
called a get er
to our authentication module so I'm
going to say get errs and it'd be
another property and inside here I'm
gonna say is logged in as a function
takes the state I believe and what we're
going to do here is basically just
return true or false depending on if the
token set
so if the token is set is gonna be true
or logged in if it's not it's going to
be false and now that we've done that we
can actually go back to our full bar
component
and hide these different buttons toupee
on April logged in or not so let's go
ahead and import
on that map
hitters function so it's a import object
each instruction of math and getters
from view X
and here I'm going to say computed is
equal to map getters of the
authentication module and then I want to
say is logged in
you
so that will basically grab us that
getter function and we can call it up
here to display and hide different
things so if we are logged in we want to
display
logout
maybe if we are logged in
you
this should always be displayed register
and login should not be displayed so I'm
gonna go ahead and just hide those two
buttons there say if we're not logged in
you can display those
you
up here we probably only wanted to splay
this if we're logged in so let's go
ahead and save that and see what happens
all right so right now token is null so
we're not logged in but if I were to
register with something new such as like
hello world 999 when we log in we now
get that projects button to show up we
get that logout button the show up
alright so let's go ahead and commit
what we have for now and then move on
so since we're here messing with the
toolbar let's just go ahead and make the
logout button actually log us out so
what is logging out basically in our
sense of our application is just going
to be setting that token to null right
so if we go back to our tent ocation
remember we have a set token mutation
which we can call
so if I just go to the toolbar I want to
make sure I'm at that mutation
I'll say methods is equal to a patient's
acid
pass it that function that we want to be
able to use
you
and then now that we have that function
could simply go up here to logout and if
we click that button I want to set token
to null
so if you go back here
it refresh the page
okay so notice here when I click log out
register went away or sorry the
project's button went away and the
logout button went away
now our show to register and login and
we can also check the store notice that
token is set to null now
I think what we also want to do though
is we want to redirect the user to the
login page whenever we click logout so
maybe instead of mapping a mutation
we could either create an action or we
could just create e a logout
functionality here so I think it'd be
better to just create an action called
logout so if we go back to
authentication make a new action called
logout
that only needs a commit basically we
need the same thing so commit set token
to null
and then we needed a router dot push
slash login
I don't think we have a route for login
yet but we will create that in a second
but going back to the toolbar instead of
doing map mutations I'm going to say map
actions
and I'm going to bring out the logout
action I'm just going to call log out
here
so let's just make some user and log
them in and now that we click logout it
should redirect us to login which we
don't have a really of you created for
that yet but we can do that in a second
well so what we haven't implemented yet
is the ability for a user to login
so let's go ahead and try to do that now
let's go back to our just commit log out
here
it to further if I go to my view I'm
gonna make a new component called login
and I'm just going to copy and paste
from register because it's gonna be
basically the same thing with different
mutations and actions oops
login
so copies the register component and
made a login view here if I go to router
let's go ahead and make a
a login route
and inside the login route let's just do
login here this is all showing up
all right so now we have login instead
of register for the button we need to
say login so I'm gonna go down here to
the button to say fingerprint
I say login see that
and that's good to go
um instead of register error I'm gonna
rename all everywhere I see register to
login so
actually suited me a me um
just do this manually I don't mess up
the realization
hmm so register should become log in
register should become login
[Music]
all right so none of these states
mutations or actions that actually
exists on the authentication so let's go
ahead and add those to so I'm going to
say set a register email password in
email or error and say login
hmm
actions instead of a register action we
also need a login action
sets login error
you know login
you
same functionality basically in fact we
could probably abstract this to a
function since this is very very similar
but to keep it simple I'm just going to
repeat myself
you notice here the same same method
we're basically changing the URL and
we're changing the error and the
parameters that we're sitting in so we
could just make a helper function up
here that does a kind of shared code
between register and login but that's
another abstraction which kind of makes
stuff a little bit harder to understand
we just want to quickly look at code so
let's not worry about that right now
so again we have a login action which
should work now it tries to log into
that login endpoint with the login email
login password there's an error will
display and the alert if not we're going
to push the token or set the token and
then we redirect to the home page
and now we just need the mutations for
those three store and values that we
added so I'm gonna say sets
set login and then here I'm just going
to say state
login
all right so let's see if this works so
first I'm
I'm gonna make testing at gmail.com
password 1 2 3 4 5 6 I'm gonna register
and this failed because I think that
user Ortiz
sure does so I'll do testing one then
just for that
I'm going to log out and make sure that
login works as this was testing one but
a log in with that same username and
password and at worked as well
awesome so we have register and we have
login working
we have logout working we're hiding and
showing different buttons based on the
token being set
um let's go ahead and what we have for
this login functionality and then we can
move on to something else so let's move
on to actually displaying the ability to
like add projects and add tasks and
stuff like that so the first thing we
need to start out with is kind of like a
projects panel so if we go to the main
view here or home view this is kind of
what we're looking at right here so I'm
going to actually rename this to
projects
and in my router I'm just going to go
ahead and change that to well
instead of home I'm going to say
projects I'm gonna change that the
projects
projects
go ahead and get rid of all this stuff
back in it or stuff in in a second
you
all right so on this project page the
first thing I want to kind of display is
a panel on the left the title that says
projects and then inside that panel I
want to display a list of my projects
and then an input box at the bottom so
we can create a new project
so first thing is the whole idea of a
panel is something that we're going to
be using throughout the application so
if we go to our components folder and
just make a new one called panel that
view
go ahead and scaffold that out
you
all I want to do here is I'm going to
make a if give us some classes which are
kind of pre built in to beautify so I'm
gonna say white right I'm say white and
elevation of two
and that's just going to make a raised
white panel and
inside that raised white panel or card I
mean I want to declare a toolbar
make sure that it is flat I'm gonna say
dents I'm gonna say dark and I'm gonna
say color of
then inside that toolbar I want to say
be little bar title it's going to be
equal to whatever the user passed in a
property so I'm gonna say title is
something that a user can pass into this
component and down here of course we're
going to need props I say title is going
to be a string
and inside the
title actually I think that's good
enough for the title underneath the tool
bar what we want to do is create
something called a slot so I'm going to
say div class of time left for padding
right for heading top of to padding
bottom of two and inside of that div I'm
just going to add a slot
no one passes anything MSA knows lock on
mind
all right so now we have a panel which
we can kind of use throughout our
application and then of course we need
to define it as a global I'm going to
say here I'm going to say view component
own int dot annal is equal to panel and
of course make sure you bring that in
and all bring that in
that view
you
so almost done in the projects out view
file now we could just simply do
panel here and I'm going to pass it
title is equal to projects
so now when we save this we should see a
panel that is defined here so we have
projects here with no slot content
defined and if we wanted to make
something render here we just simply
pass it in here so I'm going to say each
one esteem
you
notice that that title will then render
here and we can render Road whatever we
want inside of this
you
well so we made a shared component or a
global component called panel which we
can use throughout our application um
let's go ahead and do some layout here
so that's not right next to the side of
it so instead of using a div home I'm
just going to do a V container so V
container
BAM
I'm going to leave that out for now
back in the container we want to be
layout
you
laya of course we want AV flex and this
flex is going to be I'm going to say
small of four so it's going to be four
columns and then inside there I'm going
to put our panel
all right so now we have a panel to the
left called projects and let's just go
ahead and create one for now just so we
kinda have a better visualization of
what we're doing on the right so 8 plus
4 is 12 and this one is going to be
called tasks projects and tasks
you
awesome and let's just add a little bit
of padding to that glass is evil
Oh
again what I said we're doing is we're
just going to render out a text field
here where we can
add a new project and then we're going
to need to render out a list of those
projects
mmm so before we get too ahead of
ourselves let's make a new component
called projects view
you
it might be a little confusing because
we have a vehicle projects and we have a
component called projects so I need to
rename this the project view or
something but
I'll just I'll keep it as is and see how
confusing it is
so inside here let's just go ahead and
import projects from
you
that Onan slash projects dot view
[Music]
I'll say components is equal to projects
and go ahead and just instead of doing
this panel here I'm going to just render
that projects thing
we're going to start defining and then
I'll put the panel inside the projects
you
see intere because it does not sound
like
all right
so now we have this kind of refactor so
it's just is simply going to be projects
and this will probably just say tasks in
a bit and in our projects panel what we
want to do is we want to list out text
field
so
can create or we can create a record
right here I'm going to say
textfield
and we just want to kind of like
allow the user to type in the new name
of their project so I'm gonna say C
leaseholder is going to be
I project need not save this and make
sure everything is correctly alright so
we have a text field called my project
name and then we also need like a Smit
button so I'm gonna say B button
you
going to have a create on it
in fact let's just do a little bit of
flex grid stuff so we can lay it out
okay I'm going to say inside here it's
going to be the B layout
and of course we need to be flexible
wrap
you
this is basically so we can have a
button on the right
feel on them so
just do this put the text field in the
v8 a small eight
the button
well
of course I like adding icons to my
button so let's just add a V icon here
you
it adds circle
leave that
awesome and of course
we should do a little bit of margin
right
[Music]
and we can fix the style and stuff in a
second so let's see the button it
probably also be color of green
let's give it a virgin top of two
[Music]
it just moves down a little bit
let's give it dark and see what happened
all right so we have a crate button now
that looks a little bit nicer it's a
little bit down further line up with
this
[Music]
so similar to what we did at the login
and register we need to listen to when
the keys change on the text field and
then update the store and of course we
also need to set the value to something
that's coming from that store
so if I were to go back to my store
let's just assume that we have another
module called Project CAS just to simply
copy and paste what we have here
you
you
I mean needing to reuse that like HTTP
stuff so let's just do actions ITER's
State and stuff so we're just good to go
now
and of course in the main index on Jays
file we need to include that so
let's include that projects module here
and now we should be able to use that in
our view application so first thing is
I'm going to create something in our
state called new project aim gonna be
null and then I need a new mutation to
set that new project name that's going
to be state and named Oh state that new
project name is able to name
so then here of course we need to bind
value I'm going to be new project name
we need to make sure we include those
who import map mutations app state from
UX
we're gonna say map state
projects now because we're using the
projects module and we need a new
project
and then for methods
you
mutations
set new project name
you
again when we do inputs we just need to
pass set new project name
ISIL is verify that this is working as
expected so I'm gonna type hello that's
sending off the mutations for set
project name and we're seeing that
update get reflected here in the view X
state
so I guess the last step is we just need
to send off in action to the backend to
actually create this project name once
we click that submit button so if we go
back to the projects module alright so
let me just copy and paste one of the
actions here that we have a good
starting point
I'm going to say create project
commit a state
that's going to do an HTTP request to
projects it's going to a post request
and then we're going to pass the title
the state dot new project name in fact I
probably should call that new project
title
so let us be refactor that but anyway
once that's successful what we're going
to do is you're just going to MIT end
project ADA
let's not worry about errors right now
and then we'd have a projects array here
we should probably loop over at some
point
so what we need to do is in the
mutations make a new one called
project I'm going to say eight dot
project stop push project
so we can keep track of the new projects
we create and then of course we need to
set the project knee successful to go
back to also set new project name say
null
so I think we're almost done with this
but the only thing we're missing is the
hole
header if I go back to HTTP here I need
to make sure I add a header so I'm gonna
say headers is equal to authorization
that's gonna be bearer I grab from the
store be token from that authentication
module that we have
hmm
all right so we did a lot of stuff let's
just check to see what errors we may
have so I type in a new product name
called hello world
and then when I click create
we forgot to bind the create project
go back here in for map actions
we need to make sure we include that
method
click this
just need to make sure we call it
let's try again create sending-off and
request to API slash projects rating a
401 unauthorized let's look at the
network tab and see what's going on here
and saying my JWT is malformed
you
so let's look at the headers
and for some reason the token is not on
the headers so let's go back to http
that I maybe spell something headers
authorization
error date ostentation
hmm maybe it's just gonna refresh the
page correctly so let me just do a hard
refresh here hello world like create
you
oh okay so the issue is is we're not
even logged in so I don't think we
should be showing this view if we're not
logged in so there may be a different
way and I'll probably look this up to
see if there's a different way to
redirect but we try to hit the projects
page here are the project view
without being logged in
Gosei mounted is a function and then
when we're mounted just check to see if
the token we don't have so I need to do
computed
app state
indication actually no map eaters
is fogged in
[Music]
so if we're not logged in go ahead and
redirect to the login page
you
map inners is not defined ever have to
import it so after Gators from the UX
what happens here
all right so now it's gonna make me a
log in every time I type hello world
here now great that going to app in the
project so now I have a project so right
here it created the project successfully
in our back-end the only thing we need
to do now is just kind of display it in
a list
let's visualize that really quickly
inside of my projects panel up here I'm
just going to creative
I'm just going to loop over my project
so v4 project in projects
and make sure you map the project state
some state projects
we could simply just render out the
project title here if we want it to
oh I need to be bind
is going to be project
like to return
that one
I don't like this insolent so I'm going
to just plus one
let's read set to my serve
you
[Music]
see
absolutely abortion before sandy at the
top
it's only logged get login now
my awesome project my clique creates
notice that the project is now rendered
because we did a b4 so I'm making some
progress let me just go ahead and commit
what we have and we I can create more
logic in a second
you
so the next thing we want to do is when
the projects component is mounted we
want to fetch all the projects that the
user has and just render it in this list
here because if I were to not restart
this page or refresh this page and log
back in notice that we did create
projects on that user but there's
nothing that's showing up so let's move
back to that project stop view file
and let's also open up the project store
in let's create a new action called
fetch projects
Big D can take the commit function
in the state
and what we're gonna do here is just
return and the same thing that we did
before
on second
all right so we're gonna do an HTTP
method so we create that object and
we're gonna do a get request on projects
and of course we don't need to pass it
any parameters so it should just return
everything that is attached step
projects and once we get our project
data back actually we don't need state
here we're gonna do a new commit called
set projects and the back ends going to
return an array so data is going to be
an array of projects already so if we're
doing a commit action we need to make
sure we create that mutation I'm going
to go down here and say is that project
state projects and then I'm just going
to simply overwrite state thought
projects is equal to projects
as an empty right here so we should be
good to go we save this and now we
should be able to map those actions and
call that when our projects on it is
melted
you
so let's go to our
projects component since I'm in the
project view right now and what we want
to do is when this component is mounted
we are going to fish the projects so I
simply just need to go up here at a
mounted function call
to say this dot fish projects
as simple as that it's going to run that
action which is going to commit that
projects data and we should see that
reflected so I'm going to log in we see
that it called set projects here
which the pale
turned was an array of two projects so
Jaques is set on the state here so
projects and then inside projects we
have another attribute called projects
might be a little confusing but hey it
works and then you see that those are
rendered up here and we can also go to
our network tab and see that we made a
request to our projects endpoint at API
slash projects look at the response and
we have two projects returned
so pretty straightforward as to how to
fetch projects and how to create
projects now the two other pieces of
functionality we kind of need for
projects is we need to be able to edit
this title and we need to be able to
delete the project
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
try to add a button here which is like a
pencil button and when you click it it's
going to make this become a text field
so that we can edit it as needed so
let's go back to our project stop view
file and find where we are
rendering that project title which is
here on line seven
hmmm so instead of rendering bat let's
just go ahead and
make an icon
is going to be a pencil
we'll find out in a second
I have to do a little bit of layout /v
flex to get this to work out correctly
in fact I should say edit not pencil
so save that we have pencils next to our
text now which is step in the right
direction
we want to make sure that the layout is
set up correctly so let's just go ahead
and do a V layout here
you
and in heroes do we flex
and we want this to be analyst to say if
you fix a nine and the rest could be a
three let's make the title be on the
left and we can make that edit button be
on the right
you
mmm okay so making some progress let's
align the text to the left so on the the
Flex here I can say class let's say text
X X s left and that's a built in class
for beautified to kind of align stuff to
the left all of my text will be aligned
to the left now
I just add a little bit of margin to the
bottom of these so let's see each div
I'm into a class of margin bottom of to
see if that's enough looks a little bit
better and of course I'm going to say
that this is a project down here I'm
going to make a new style
I'll dot project and that's going to say
margin art that's going to be font size
of 18 pixels
see that's big enough
it's okay
be something bigger like 24 and then
I think I want to add a little bit of
space above this so if we go to the
panel I'm going to say class is adding
top of four and see if that pushes it
down
but then on the wrong thing
you
so I'm just going to do margin-top of
you here instead
there we go that looks a little and then
this is going to give it a little bit of
margin too
the margin top of four just to push that
whole thing down get a little bit of
space all right
so again what we're trying to do is when
we click on this edit button we want to
change this to a V text field so that we
can edit the hello world project title
so if I go back to where we are
rendering that title out
here hmm we're gonna kind of have two
things that need to interchange
depending on if the project is an edit
mode or if it's not in edit mode
you
so let's just pretend that project has
an is edit mode boolean so I'm gonna do
a span and say B if
project dot is edit mode we're going to
display something
which is going to be the project title
otherwise we're going to display a V
text field e text field
again we do the opposite of that and you
probably use a switch case as well I
think you has a switch case support so I
say if it's not in edit mode we're
simply not going to display the text
field
you
okay then inside this text field we're
going to do value is going to be equal
to project on title
back to this
save this and make sure this is
displaying correctly
of
and extra space
you
I think I have these swaps so that needs
to be if it is edit mode in this if it's
not- mode
hmm okay so you saw it was displaying a
textfield before and that was just
because I had the boolean swapped so now
if I click on this icon what we want to
do is change the project's is edit mode
boolean to true
down here for the button I'm going to
say at click that edit mode
and pass it the project here
you
so let's go and actually ten like we
have a mutation that we can call so here
we're gonna map mutations and call set
edit mode and that needs to be true
actually so wherever I called set edit
mode let's just say that's going to be a
value of true
I always keep like that so set edit mode
and if I go to projects and go to my
mutations let's just add another one
called set edit mode state and that's
going to be project then inside here
we're going to do project dot is edit
mode is equaled
you
let's see if that actually changes our
state as we click things
like this
the edit mode is set down here and his
MANET mode is edit mode is set to true
and the issue that we're having here is
nothing is being reflected in our state
and that's because is edit mode doesn't
actually exist on the project so this is
kind of a nuance in regards to using
view where the UI is only going to bind
the stuff that actually exists so what
we need to do instead is if we go back
instead of doing project on is edit mode
true we need the first import view
you
and then down here instead of just doing
this we need to save you a set project
is edit mode and then we need the
passage through
in the
make sure that it binds correctly to
that boolean once we set it
but oh this music of
all right so if I go back look this
notice that it changes to the text field
and right now we don't have a way to go
back because we don't have like a cancel
button or a check button so let's kind
of add that so let's go back to our
project stop view and I'm going to add a
check
down here
you
the same same ideas gonna have a check
icon when you click it it's gonna call
unset edit mode so we're going to assume
that we have an unset at it mode we're
going to go to our
down here and at this point it's
probably safe to assume that edit mode
is defined on the project because it
can't be true unless you set it
so I should be able to do project out is
that it Modi's equal to false but just
in case let's just keep it as is like
this
go back we should have a checkbox that
shows up of course we need to probably
do a B if to display it and hide it
anything so if I click on it B pencil
but going to edit mode if I click on the
check it goes back to non edit mode
let's make sure we toggle those
correctly
going back here let's find that check
icon I created and I'm gonna say V if
project dot is edit mode its false and
then for this one
the edit mode is true we want to display
a check
so now we can toggle between them
pretty awesome so let's go down to the
style and let's just do
I think we want to make it so when we
hover over this we have a cursor so is
this actually old
class of icons so if we go to our style
and say icon cursor is a pointer
just so we get some feedback as a user
when we hover over stuff we probably
also want to say icon hover background
actually has to be color of
make it gray I guess
short color was before
so now it's a little bit darker when we
hover over it
oh so we're kind of getting closer to
implementing this edit functionality so
now if we were to change the value of
hello world to what is up of them like
that notice that nothing changes because
we haven't actually bound to the input
call back on the project edit so we need
to go back and go here and say add a new
mutation called set project title state
project
actually this is going to be a message
so I'm gonna say project title
and then project that title is equal to
title
mutation we can set the title and if we
go back to our projects view we again
need to make sure we grab that mutation
so I'm going to go ahead and grab that
set project title from the project's
module
and then when we change the value of
this let me say at input I want to go
ahead and just call set project title I
want to pass it the event
I don't know if I need to do this let me
just try this so set project title and
then take a object
object is going to have the project so
I'm gonna say project and then also the
title is going to be equal to the event
you
you
I think I'm I'm beginning some type of
air
Lindt air or something this is not
single lime
you
oh you know what I'm doing wrong I have
I'm updating the wrong thing hold on
inputs declared twice on this I'm
updating the wrong text field so if I go
up here to the text field we're supposed
to be updating let me just add input to
that so now we're calling set project
title with the project and then the
event which is going to be in the text
we may need to verify this in a second
but let's see what happens if we run
this so login and I'm going to go ahead
and try to edit this by adding an
exclamation mark it dispatched that
mutation
and we have the payload we have the
project and we also have a new title
that we want change it to
then if I go into my projects array
notice that the corresponding project
has the exclamation mark so we're now
we're we are reflecting the value of the
title successfully the last part is when
we check click the check box we want to
actually persist so if I go back to that
check box here
instead of saying unset edit mode I'm
just going to say save project
you
let's go back and pretend like there's
an action I'll save
edit mode for now now let's just be
explicit and call a save project
then go back to our actions or our
projects module and create an action
called say project
basically what we want to do
is just send off a at request to the
endpoint that we have so I miss HTTP
catch on projects slash project on ID
and then this needs to be string
interpolation so we can use back ticks
okay there you go then of course we need
to pass the project that we're trying to
save and that should hit the
can save and actually persist the
project project state to the back end
and when we get a response back hush for
at this point we really need to do much
so we just let's just delete that for
now
commit what we want to do is actually
yes so if I say if successfully what
we're going to do is we're going to
commit and say unset edit load project
all right so it's gonna persist it if it
was successfully persisted to the back
end we then just just say or unset it
from edit mode so it's going back to the
normal view let's try doing this and see
what happens so I'm going to go to the
check pencil add a couple of exclamation
marks and click the check box notice
that it went back to the normal view
instead of the edit mode and they made a
network request to project / - we sent
the payload of title hello world blah
blah blah and we got a response back of
the new object so now when i refresh the
page and log back in
notice that we have that item our that
title persistent now well so we're
making some good progress we have the
ability to create new projects we have
the ability to edit projects
one thing that we don't have is when I
click this edit button it doesn't focus
on this automatically so a cool little
attribute we can add two V text field is
auto focus so let me go and say auto
focus here so now whenever we click on
that it should automatically focus on
there and it did mm-hmm what we also
want to do is if we press ENTER on our
keyboard it would be nice if it just
does that save thing for us
you
so let's go to
text field we're going to say key up
enter but basically if the user were to
have a key up event on the inner we're
just going to say save project and pass
it project
and this is basically doing the same
thing as clicking the check button let's
save that and see if that works
I'm gonna click a pencil add something
click enter
notice that that got persisted to
Project number three now
all right so now we're kind of on the
last
basically we need to be able to delete a
project from that list so you know the
drill basically we're gonna have to have
a new action called delete project so
I'm just gonna copy and paste this all
delete project it's going to take a
project it's going to make a delete
request to project slash ID we don't
need the past data then once the project
is successfully deleted
we want to remove project from our list
so we're going to need a new mutation
down here I'll remove project and that's
just going to splice out the project
from the list so I'm gonna say state
that projects not splice state that
projects dot index of project and then
one and this is how you to remove
something from an array so just going to
find the index where this one exists and
just splice it from the array
you
you
so now in order to use that action let's
go back to our view component let's go
ahead and bring that in and let's go
ahead and make a new button our new icon
which is going to be a delete icon and
we're going to be calling the leap
project when we click it so here I'm
gonna say delete we only want to show it
when we are in edit mode and want to
call delete project on that if I go
ahead and save that
log back in let's see let's click on
actually we want to show it all the time
I think
they've seen me completely so now we
always have that trashcan that we when
we click it's just going to delete it we
go to the network tab notice that made a
delete request who project to and if I
were to refresh and log back in that
project has been deleted from the list
and delete everything and see what works
one thing I also notice is when I press
ENTER on this text field that it does
not create the project so let's go ahead
and try to implement that as well so
very similar to before when we click on
create or you enter we want to write the
project
so here in the text field when we do a
key up we just want to say create
project give it that function go ahead
and save this go back and now when I
press ENTER on my keyboard it's going to
create it for us what remain a lot of
progress let's go ahead and commit what
we have this is going to be called
editing elite projects all right so
before we move on to this tasks panel I
want to go ahead and abstract some
things that we can reuse components
because task is basically going to be
very similar to this projects panel so
first thing I want to abstract is this
bottom create thing or section that we
have I want to have a component which
has a gray button where I can change
this text dynamically through a prop and
of course invoke different callback
functions depending on what we want
so let's start with this right here
so if we go back to our project site
view file notice that this bottom
section here
we want this is what we want to kind of
abstract into a separate component so
down here I'm gonna say a new file
called create record view go ahead and
scaffold that up
and
that same layout of code that we had
other file
and let me just go ahead and
that doesn't even just here so say great
record
you
make sure we have the components
components
and of course we need to import that so
you
okay so if we wanted to abstract this
into a different class basically we just
wanted to allow the props to be passed
in for setting like placeholder text and
we want to emit certain events when
things changed so the first thing I can
do here or placeholder I'm just going to
say this will be placeholder
so up here x8 props we have lace holder
and then inside projects we just simply
pass
you
place holder is equal whatever I just
copied out
let's see this was
I project is odd or something like that
this so this probably won't actually
work out of the box as there's gonna be
errors
so before we make much progress let's
just comment out things we don't want
so I can show you some progress let's
see unfortunately I can't really easily
calm down crap so
I feel like it cut it out or something
all right so different approach let me
just go ahead and make placeholder
functions and stuff for all this and
then we can refactor as is so we're
passing in the placeholder text that's
awesome what we want to do is when the
input text changes on this text field
that of calling a function we want to
emit on input
event
now our existing component can just
listen to that and call our function as
needed so let's go to here we can say on
input is equal to that new project name
with whatever that was so
okay and then when the value is passed
they basically we need to have value as
a prop to
value as a prop and then instead of new
project name I'm gonna say value go back
to here I'm going to pass a value in
and then on key enter
instead of doing
we just want to say MIT create
so then over here we can just listen to
the create event and just simply call
create project
so we have that abstracted into a prop
this into a prop
and then on inputs we pretty much emit
on input with the past event and then
for this one when we hit enter we're
going to emit a create there might be a
shorthand to do this since we're just
propping our yep propagating that event
up maybe just pass it event or something
I'm not sure that'll feel free to
comment if there's a better way to do
line seven same thing with when we click
on the button we want to simply just
emit create and luckily our projects
component is going to call Cory project
on that already
these are persistent so we don't need to
change those so let's go ahead and save
this and see what errors we may have
you
refresh this page and see if we're
getting any type of errors
it looks like we're not so
the prop is my project is and we're
passing that in here
a I project name
when I type something click create
same logic as before so it's sending off
that event to create the project let me
just refresh the page and to make sure
that's all system and working as I did
before
so if you noticed how easy it was to
kind of abstract that little bit of
functionality into my own view component
and now basically anywhere my app where
I want to have something that looks like
this I could use it and we're going to
be using that in our test panel in just
a second and before we move on let me
just make sure I aligned something to
the right so I'm gonna say text small
right this crate button should be as far
to the right as possible
so for this other piece of functionality
which we're going to be using in the
test panel basically we want to create a
new component I'm going to call that
editable record
you
pull that up and we're going to be doing
the pretty much the exact same thing we
did before we're going to copy and paste
this to editable record bring it in
we're gonna find that layout section and
just copy and paste that into that
editable record
there
boom
we're going to make sure we try to call
it here so editable record
of course make sure you bring it in
inside your components
save this and let's see what we should
pass to it to make this work
so the first thing the UI's gonna be
broken since we have to kind of fix all
this stuff first first thing we want to
do is a profit is check to see if is
edit mode or not so we are going to say
bind is edit mode and we're going to
pass it
this
is edit mode so that's going to be
sending in the project that is edit mode
and then down here of course we need to
define a props array
and just to find his edit mode
you keep on going through and kind of
doing the same thing so instead of
project title here let's make it a
little bit more abstract and that's just
going to be title
so it all
sure that we're passing that in so title
is equal to project title
hmm so this we can get rid of project
that title we don't need we can use
title say project I'm gonna instead of
doing project here I'm going to call it
record so over here I must say record is
a prop we pass in and anywhere we see
project I'm gonna say record
record record
get rid of his edit mode it's not as
edit mode
you
the inputs I'm going to say emit
input and pass it the event here and
then what we need to do in the file
above is just listen to on input and
we're going to call that same
functionality so set project title
this needs to be removed see
okay let's just look through this really
quick and see if we're maybe missing
anything mm-hmm this add text right to
this because I noticed in the UI I
wasn't already onto the right
you
right so for these events this app shot
component editable record should have no
idea if it's a project or task or
whatever so instead we need to say
omit on edit
and then of course in here we need to
say on edits dispatch that mutation same
thing for this
instead we're to say omit unsaved
basically when they click the Save
button
to bind to that callback so unsaved make
sure we call that previous method we
were doing before
and then of course getting kind of
tedious so I'm gonna say on deletes
make sure that we find it
and I should say project four although
so if you notice here basically this
component has absolutely no knowledge
about if it's a project or not actually
this one used to be emit on save save
project
right so you see no instance of project
anywhere and basically this is just a
very abstract component which which
takes in props and emits events when
certain things happen which the
project's component is kind of
responsible for changing and dispatching
the actions are emanating mutations so
let's see what potentially is still
broken in the UI so first of all it
looks like none of the titles are
showing up
so we have title here down to project
title
idle should be rendered here
that should only edit our render when is
not edit mode so that's probably the
issue
let me just refresh the page and see
what errors we have
it looks like that might be working now
so
sit out and see if it's still working as
it did before refresh the page
so we have now to abstract components
which we can use in this task panel to
basically edit tasks delete tasks save
tasks and create new tasks and all we
have to do is pass in certain props to
do so
so let's just go ahead and commit what
we have I'm gonna say editable records
and create records
okay so now for the kind of the last
part of this tutorial let's go ahead and
finish out the implementation of that
asks panel so if I go back to my
projects out view view let's assume we
have one called tasks here
have a new component called tasks I'm
going to create that and make sure that
exists in my components
and then I'm going to make a new
component called tasks that view athol
that up I'm
this it's going to be very similar to
projects top view
the other one so let me go to this see
what we got
so similarly we're going to need a panel
but it's going to have a title of asks
boom that seems like that's working fine
and inside that tasks panel we're gonna
do something very similar where we're
going to be looping over
tasks some say and brought our tests and
tasks
or a V for tasks and task I'm going to
get the ID for the key
is to make sure that we grab this but
we're going to do a little bit smaller a
font size so I'm going to eat instead
for a task
and then here I can just say tasks our
description for now
let's see what it has no matching
for some reason it's not Muslim enough
Luke it's working fine now so
let me just refresh the page in case
we're getting in Severus
our beer method task is not defined on
the end but it's okay
all righty so now let's try to
implementing the store so notice before
we had a projects in the store let's go
and create something for the tasks so in
the store I'm going to add a new one
called tasks ojs
and I'm just gonna copy and paste
projects and kind of bring it down we
have a good starting point
let me do all this
okay
okay so I created our tests module make
sure we include it here I'm going to say
tasks
and make sure you include that module in
your main store object
so for the first thing we're doing we
just want to rent her over the tasks
right which that should be set up ready
to go
um
actually it's not set up because we
forgot to map the actions so here I'm
going to go over and I'm going to copy
this we're going to be using a lot of
the same map actions mutations in state
and what we want to do is inside of the
computed
we want to call map state
going to take tasks and that's going to
take asks
this is obviously going to throw an
error because we're going to use so let
me just give her those for now
you
so no more errors anymore
you
all right so the first thing we want to
do is if we go back to this component
here and we click on one of these we
want to make sure that we set the
current project that we're trying to
edit so going back to our project module
let's go ahead and say make a new
mutation called set current project
and state that project
just to keep track of what project were
kind of a clicked on
that current project instead of just
project
you
okay so then in our projects on view
when we click on one of these editable
records so on click
we want to call set current project is
equal to project of course we haven't
brought that in so let's go and grab
that mutation
you
and then for editable record we don't
have an on-click callback yet so let's
go here and let's go back to our title
and basically if someone clicks it I
want to call on click I want to emit on
click
you
so that we can keep track of what
we have clicked so if I go back to my
view debugger and click on some of these
notice that the current project is
changing as I click different projects
here
you
but we want to take that a step further
Sukie set current project should
probably an action which fetches the
tasks as well so what we can do is in
the tasks module let's add a new action
called fetch tasks for current project
that's gonna be something that has MIT
probably going to have root State
Shammi call it set tasks for project
going to take a project as a second
so very similar to before let's just
grab the HTTP method here I'm going to
just copy and paste that so we have
something to work with
you
so that's going to fetch all the tasks
for this project ID that we're passing
in for the action and I'm say set tasks
is equal to data
and of course make sure that we have a
mutation called set tasks state tasks
this the RM say state task is equal to
tasks
and then now when we actually
click on a task we like the projects
when we call set current project what we
want to do instead is make a new method
called set current project I'm sure I'm
gonna call it current project clicked
call it project click sorry I might
change my mind a lot so what we want to
do here I just say this dot set current
project or in a passive project then
we're gonna say this dot fetch asks for
project
and then make sure we just map the
actions for tasks here
fetch asks for project
all righty so basically what we should
have seen is if we click on that tasks
over here we click on a project that
mean it should make two mutations so
it's going to first call set current
project which it is
then it should make a request
to the tasks which I don't think it did
so let's kind of go back and debug why
that might not be happening
make sure we call it fetch tasks for
project an action and we should be able
to call it correctly so if I go back
here
in action here Rajat clicked oh I know
why so we made this new function but we
didn't actually use it so let's go back
up here and call our two clicked
when we click on this notice that it
makes a request for the tasks this is
going to return an empty array because
we don't actually have any and that
should populate our tasks up here when
it actually is defined
and we'll see that in a second so let's
go and start working on the next piece
of functionality which is going to be
the create record so if I go back to our
task component I'm just going to go
ahead and add a create record section
well I need to dot dot which is gonna be
like a task placeholder
they set new tasks when it's the input
changes I'm gonna say set new task name
the valley is going to be a new task
name and create is gonna be create to
the task so very similar to the
project's but we need to make sure that
we bring those in so let's map new task
name
and four methods let's bring in map
action from tasks that's going to be
called create task
and then we need some mutations for
masking mutations
that's going to be called set new task
name
and of course those don't actually exist
yet so let's go back to tasks and we
need to create one called set new task
name
state that new task name is equal to new
task name
and then we need the whole create task
here someone's going to copy and paste
basically what we have here and then
edit it as needed
the way we did it with the back end I
think we actually need the project so
what we can do is pretend like we have
the project ID
I think it might be that
you
let me just double-check that I'm doing
that right
at root state projects
that ID
so we're basically just grabbing that
idea from the root state so we can know
what tasks to append it to doing a post
requests have the description here we're
calling a pin task so make sure we have
that
asked here so I'm going to say state
contests that push tasks
you
let's see if this is all working
you
you
got a comma here
or gods
chins
yeah
let's see how this works
my great record is not included so make
sure we also did components and then
make sure we create record let me just
copy and paste that import from the
project so
oh here should we import that save it
also notice here in our tasks panel we
have the same pretty much component that
we had over here but it has a little bit
different placeholder text now if I type
in and clean my room
at setting new tasks name which is
updating our test module new test name
here and when I click create
an error and that's because let's see I
don't think I click the project yet so
that's something we need to kind of fix
basically we shouldn't show this panel
unless the current project is clicked so
if I go back to our projects view
and I grabbed map state map state
and make sure that we are including
checked
basically we don't want to display this
section if we haven't selected a project
yet so if it is selected we'll display
it otherwise we don't
to get that error because there's no way
to actually create a task unless you've
clicked one yet so let's click on
awesome and then let's try to create a
task
current project is selected of ID of
five and now when I click create it
should try to make a request to the task
endpoint which it did that was
successful or return to 200 status and
it sent back our task and then we
appended it to our tasks array
so at this point what do we notice well
this is very similar to this over here
so let's go ahead and bring in that
other component we created and try to
reuse it
so
projects I'm going to bring in editable
record
Riggin in here make sure you exist in my
components
mmm and I'm gonna do very very similar
logic by just bringing that in so edible
record here
going to go back to my task component
instead of just displaying the
description let's display the editable
record and instead here when I say task
is edit mode ask set task title
tasks clicked
you
actually let's see what happens if I try
to comment
does it there
I don't ask work
a set of title we want to do description
display clean my room
we don't wanna do any logic when we
click it so let's just get rid of that
but the other logic should say fairly
consistent so let me go back and see if
I can like
to be able to style that task in a
second so some things that we don't have
yet is we don't have the set edit mode
or save task or delete task created and
set task description it's not pretty yet
so let's just kind of work our way down
these inputs and try to create what we
need
so here I'm going to say a mutation of
set task description
you
that's going to take a ask in a
description basically say task
description it's a description
make sure I rename title description
here um set edit mode so I'm gonna go
here set edit mode state ask and view
dot set this is very similar to how we
had it before so let's just go ahead and
copy that in
so just set edit mode here and then make
sure we include view from the up import
and we also have save tasks oh let me
just copy save project and delete
project and just kind of change that as
needed into our actions so save ask I'm
going to take a task
hit tasks test that ID asked
and delete tasks
ask remove ask
you
forgot to bring in the unset edit mode
so I'm going to do onset at anode be
false
hey let's see if we're missing anything
you're missing removed tasks but we need
to make sure we at
a state test that by state on tasks
index of task 1
all right let's finally we need to bring
these in so we have these actions save
tasks and delete tasks so let's bring in
lead tasks and save task set that task
description is tation
said edit mode is a mutation
and let's see if this works
click on this let's see if we can edit
the task
edited the tasks and saved it over here
awesome
and then if we try to delete
one of these new tasks here make sure
that that is working so request failed
with 404 that's because we're trying to
hit slash task when it needs to be tasks
so if I go back to my
Elite tasks method I just need to add
slash tasks instead
that delete that okay so that's
basically all working as we did before
that's basically working as the
project's did over here then we can also
just change our projects as needed to
fetch different tasks here
so I think the last thing I'm going to
work on for this tutorial is putting a
checkbox here that can mark a task as
completed or not
so to do that the first thing we want to
do is kind of extend the existing
editable record module that we have let
me commit what we
here are some say
you
and let me get back to
Sulekha saying in the editable record we
want to be able to include a slot so we
can pass in the ability to render stuff
to the left of our text fields in
title
or whatever it may be so what I'm gonna
do is going to add a new element called
slot
basically whatever I pass in inside my
projects or tasks component is going to
render to the left of this text so an
example if I go to tasks and for my
editable record if I say I'll do like h1
hello
make sure I have the closing tag outside
of that save this we should say hello to
the left and of course this is just
going to be on top right now because
we're not floating it to the left Ernie
what what we want to do in our case is I
just want to make a checkbox
following what we've done over here just
get an icon but I go and put that inside
the slot here
going to go ahead and give her that
stuff for now and save this and
hopefully that is
not what we're looking for we're looking
for something called a check box
so let me oh sorry I forgot to put it
underscore here check underscore box all
right so when we do that we get a check
box
but we need to be able to toggle between
if it's a checkbox or if it's not filled
out so there's another icon that we
could use called checkbox outline blank
so what we want to do here is basically
just render
some a different icon depending on if
we're completed so I could say task dot
completed and do a ternary operator and
just simply return check box if we're
completed or return check box outlined
blank if we are not completed go ahead
and save that if we go back notice that
these two tasks are not yet completed
additionally when we click on these
check boxes we want to kind of toggle
that completed state so let's just do
that let's add a at click and I'll say
toggle completed and then that's going
to be a method which accepts tasks and
of course that doesn't exist here so we
need to go back to our
tasks I'm going to say that's going to
be an action so I'm say talk will
completed is an action
so we'll go back to our store load up
the tasks module I'm going to add a new
one called toggle completed
and basically what this is going to do
is we're going to do a commit to set
that to either true or false so I'm
gonna say
we'll completed
um
I had to have a different name so
I don't think I said that habit of name
so I'm gonna do a mutation with the same
name for now I don't know that's a good
idea but let's just do it and basically
task doc completed is going to be equal
to a stock completed
you
I do believe if we go to the console
when we try to fetch tasks
that completed is indeed a attribute on
that task so we should be good we don't
need to do view dot set because we're
actually handling that on the my sequel
databases table so we have a mutation
which is going to kind of modify or
toggle that completed bullying and what
we need to do inside this toggle
completed action is simply commit that
hmm but after we've admitted that we
need to call save tasks here
and actually instead of doing an action
maybe we should just instead get rid of
this action sorry kind of changing up my
plans made coding which isn't
necessarily bad to do but instead of it
being a action let's just make it a
mutation
and what we can do is when we click on
this
I'm going to add a method down here
called check
clicked I think that's what I just had a
call and we're simply just gonna say
this dot welcome completed tasks and
then I'm gonna say this dot save ask
past that task at Clifton old
I think I could have done this in the
action
it could just fire an action off of
in action from this action but I think
it gives us a little bit more
flexibility if I don't actually save it
when I toggle it but I want the mutation
to just toggle the state and then I want
the disk component to be responsible for
saving it I don't want the action to do
both of that
so let's see if this works so if I go
and click on my project here and I click
on this task here first of all it's
sending off a request to the network and
completed is true if I go to my view X
or view / e bugger we see that talk--i
completed was fired completed to set the
true if I cleared again completed is set
to false and it's saving that task so
let me just make a couple of ask and
make sure that these get persisted when
I create them and just refresh the page
just to verify that everything is
working as before and it is ok so we're
basically at the end of our demo I mean
I could probably spend more time
sprucing up the Styles you know
obviously when I hover over this it
should be clickable or should have a
cursor when I hover over this the text
should change
um but I guess in terms of this tutorial
I don't want to spend too much extra
time I'll assume this up I think we
covered a lot of good grounds and like
examples of how to build up a single
page application and connect it to a
REST API that we created by hand so that
basically wraps up this full stack view
and add-on SJS tutorial if you have any
feedback or questions feel free to leave
them in the comments below or you can
message me on Twitter I could always use
feedback if this tutorial was too quick
or if I was jumping all over the place
feel free to tell me so and maybe I'll
make another tutorial in the future
which isn't so sporadic and on the fly a
person like tutorials that are kind of
like unplanned so you can kind of see
what I'm thinking and how my logic is
applied to when I'm making applications
and stuff alright so I think that's
basically what I'm going to be covering
in the full stack tutorial other than
deployment which I'll do in a bit one
thing I'll change is if you remember if
we go back to our store and go to the
index I disabled a plugin I'll create
create persisted state I'm just gonna
re-enable that and kind of explain what
this does basically and now when i
refresh the page I have to log in one
more time but now when i refresh the
page it's gonna cache everything that
was in my store inside local storage
meaning that I don't have to log in
again or whatnot so basically exactly
how I have my app state before I leave
and refresh that's how it's going to
load back up so if you notice I clicked
on this project and it loaded back up
for me so it's very useful in terms of
like UX because you don't want to user
to have to keep login and over and over
again just happy their state stored
locally and then once they refresh the
page or go back onto the application
everything is exactly how it was before
so in order to get our single page
application deployed out we first need
to kind of build it so I'm gonna do in
p.m. run build in the client folder and
that's going to build our view
application into a dist folder
and after that's done building what we
could simply do is just copy it from the
disk folder and put it in our public
folder in our server again that's
probably not the you know proper or best
practice way to do it but that's just
one way to deploy your application is
super simple so while that's doing that
I'm just going to build a new folder
called public okay so now that that is
done if you look at the disk older here
it created a bunch of different files so
basically what I'm going to do is just
copy the files that are in that folder
and put them in my public folder here
I just want to make sure that the public
folder is not ignored again this this
probably isn't the best way you should
probably have like a continuous
integration continuous deployment system
building up and deploying to like a
static host like s3 or something but
again this is just a quick dirty way to
get it deployed so what I'm going to do
here is I'm just going to simply add
that and commit it
my REIT bill
and then on our get repo we can simply
pull and start our Dona server to have
that hosted all right so now for
deploying this application first thing
I'm going to show you is I have a
digitalocean account and I'm gonna
create a new droplet go up here and
click click droplet create droplet I'm
going to give us a list of different OS
as we can use so I'm just going to use a
boon 2 which is the default I'll just go
ahead and say give me a default because
only gonna have this hosted for like a
minute
or a couple of minutes and then when I
could click create that's gonna go ahead
and just start creating my droplet and
then once it's done I'm gonna get an
email with the root password that I can
use
also we have the IP up here that we can
use to SSH into the gene so let's give
this a second to finish running alright
so now that this is done running let's
just go ahead and copy that IP address
and go over to my terminal I'm gonna do
SSH route at that IP address and then
I'm going to copy and paste the password
that they've emailed to me the root
password and then once you first log in
for the first time it's going to ask me
for that current password again I'm
gonna ask you to enter a new password
let me that and now we are on the server
so the first step is we want to install
node let's go ahead and just follow this
tutorial where it says you need to curl
the setup eight script or run that
fetch the necessary things that set up
node and then when that's done you need
to go ahead and run this second
committee
that's done going to run install for
nodejs
all right so now we have note installed
and we have NPM installed so before we
move on we need to also make sure we
install the Adonis CLI so let me just go
ahead and copy that run that
you
basically we need that for running our
migration scripts
it's installing let's just go ahead and
set up next step which is we need to go
to our project and go ahead and copy the
HTTP link here so I'm going to copy that
we're going to clone our project when
this is done installing so I'm going to
get clone and clone our project now we
have our project here SSH into the
server folder or I'm going to CD into
the server folder in you run NPM install
so that I install all of our
dependencies we need to Ho stored on a
server and while that's installing I'm
just going to edit this env file and in
order to host our Dona server we need to
change a couple thing though first of
all the host needs to be a zero zero
zero zero or it needs to be eighty and
then no D&V needs to be production all
the rest you can keep as is so I'm just
going to copy this and inside that
server folder here I'm going to paste
that into that env file save that and
now we can run our migration scripts so
we're going to do ad honest migration
and colon run - - force make sure we run
our migration scripts in set up our
tables fact it might have already set
that up maybe I committed
database was committed when I
the database file the sequel light was
already committed to the repo so that
was kind of my bad so technically you
don't either run your migration scripts
this should have been ignored get
ignored but if it wasn't or yeah if it
was get ignored you probably have to
rerun your migration scripts to set up
your C like so now everything at this
point is set up let's just try running
our server really quick and make sure
that it runs using node space server ojs
and if everything worked it should say
it's hosted on zero zero zero eighty
then we can go up here and try to go to
local we can try to go that IP address
here
and see what happens and so our app is
now loaded is hosted at this port on all
rights hosted at this IP port 80 you can
see that our app is running
sure that we can actually login let's
just click login and see what happens
excessively successfully logged us into
our app
oh so I mean basically you just follow
these steps if you wanted to get your
app running in production um of course
you can use other things like Heroku or
cloud compute to deploy your application
but that's just this is just one way to
do it really quickly and really cheaply
because you can have a lot of apps
running on the same droplet and this
setup wasn't too difficult the final
step is we probably want to install a
better way to run our server so let's
install a tool called PM to globally so
you MPM install global km2 and once
that's done installing I could just do
p.m. to start service and that is going
to be a tool which kind of monitors my
server and it will restart it if it were
to crash for whatever reason
that's done installing now I can do p.m.
to start River Jas
going to spawn APM - Damon on my server
so I can hit it again here
serious loading fine
Oh
so that pretty much sums up my full
stack you Adonis digitalocean deployment
tutorial you have any comments if you
want to leave me feedback up how I can
make my tutorials better feel free to do
so in the comments below I hope this
tutorial didn't go too quick and I hope
I kind of explain what I was doing in
the meantime happy coding and thanks for
watching